TO ORDER THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON UTILITY AND ENERGY.
WE HAVE A THREE BILLS BEFORE US
THIS MORNING --
THAT WE ARE GOING --
TO ADDRESS A TOUR ON CONSENT.
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL
GO WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AND ESTABLISH OUR CORE.
HOLDEN.
HERE PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
GEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN HERE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES HERE MERCY
CHIEF.
QUIRK HERE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN --
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS BEFORE WE GET TO
OUR FIRST ITEM S. B. ONE HUNDRED
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT.
S. B. NINETY FIVE BELL.
SECOND BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN HERE AYE.
EGGMAN AYE.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES BY MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK CLARK QUIRK AYE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
A QUORUM ESTABLISHED SENATOR DO
WE ARE HERE. TO TO HEAR YOUR
BILL S. B. ONE HUNDRED THE
SECOND TIME THAT IT'S BEEN IN
OUR COMMITTEE --
WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
DILIGENCE AND HARD WORK ON THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT.
ISSUE.
AND WE TURN TO YOU THIS AS A A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THAT'S THE MOTION THAT --
WE'RE RECOMMENING.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING AND SAID TO
FIND STAFF WE WORKED A VERY
DILIGENTLY AS YOU HAVE STATED
THAT JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO. ONE
OF THE GIVEN MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
FOR INVESTMENTS --
AND THE VIA THE EXPERIENCE OF A
OF YOUR STUFF TO WHO HAVE HELPED
ADJOURNMENTS THE SHAPE OF A SP
ONE HUNDRED SO THIS IS A FROM
BOTH HOUSES WITH THAT THE
EXPERTISE ON ON BOTH SIDES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO VICE CHAIR
NOW ONE OF THE RIVER MUCH FOR
ADAPTING TO PRESENT SENATE BILL.
ONE HUNDRED SENATE BILL ONE
HUNDRED PUTS CALIFORNIA ON THE
PATH 21100% CLEAN RENEWABLE
ENERGY BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IT IS THE MOST
AMBITIOUS TARGETS IN THE WORLD
FOR AN ECONOMY THAT DWARFS ALL
BUT A HANDFUL OF NATIONS.
BUT OUR EXPERIENCE SO FAR OFFERS
HARD EVIDENCE VERY HARD EVIDENCE
THAT WE CAN DRAMATICALLY EXPAND
CLEAN ENERGY WHILE ALSO GROWING
OUR ECONOMY AND PUTTING PEOPLE
TO WORK.
IN FACT CLEAN ENERGY IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY ECONOMIC SUCCESS
STORY IN CALIFORNIA.
SOLAR WIND ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
OTHER CLEAN POWER SOURCES NOW
COLLECTIVELY EMPLOY OVER HALF A
MILLION [inaudible]
OF CALIFORNIANS.
IN FACT THERE ARE MORE THAN
NEARLY TEN TIMES MORE CLEAN
ENERGY JOBS IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
THAN THEY ARE COAL MINING JOBS
IN ALL OF AMERICA.
AND THE INDUSTRY IS GROWING
ADDING JOBS FASTER THAN ALMOST
ANY OTHER SECTOR.
THIS EXPLOSIVE GROWTH HAS BEEN
SPURRED IN LARGE PART BY
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
[inaudible]
CLIMATE POLICIES.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE VERY
PROUD OF OUR PROGRESS.
CLEAN ENERGY IS NOW A POLLUTER
OF OUR ECONOMY AND IT IS HERE TO
STAY.
BUT THE INDUSTRY IS NOT CREATING
JUST ANY OLD JOBS IT'S CREATING
JOBS THAT SUPPORT THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
FAMILIES MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
IN IS DOING SO AND SO ARE MOST
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES.
IN CREATING REAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIANS OF EVERY CAL
EVERY BACKGROUND IN SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE.
AND DESPITE THE DOOMSDAY
RHETORIC WE HEARD FROM THE WE
HAVE HEARD WHEN WE PASS OUR
CURRENT RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD.
THIS IS BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARY
STORY.
JUST TWENTY YEARS AGO WE WERE 0%
OR PS WE'VE GONE FROM 00220%.
2233% THIRTY THREE TO FIT
PERCENT.
SOME OF THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE ALMOST AT 50%
TODAY BECAUSE THE MARKET SIGNALS
SENT VERY CLEARLY TO SENATE
BILL.
THREE FIFTY NOW WE WANT TO HAVE
TO ESTABLISH A PATHWAY FROM
621100% BUT GIVES US ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY AND A LONG.
A WINDOW INTO THE FUTURE.
CALIFORNIANS SPEND LESS ON THE
UTILITY BILLS AND RESIDENTS OF
ALL BUT THREE STATES AND DC.
SENATE BILL ONE HUNDRED EXHORTS
ARE TRANSITION 21100% CARBON
FREE.
SPEEDS UP SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTIES A 50% MANDATE FOR CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY. TWENTY THIRTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY IT ESTABLISHES
A NEW BENCHMARK UP 60% BY THE
YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY IT WILL HELP US
CAPTURE UNCONTROLLED METHANE
EMISSIONS FROM JERRY'S FROM
LANDFILLS AND WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS REPLACE NATURAL
GAS FROM FRACKING.
VERY MIND THIS IS METHANE THAT
IS CURRENTLY BEING FLARED OR
ESCAPING INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AND
WARMING THE PLANET.
POUND FOR POUND HAS MANY MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS VERY
KNOW VERY WELL IT'S MUCH MORE
DANGEROUS THAN CARBON DIOXIDE
IT'S A SUPER TOXIC POLLUTANTS.
THIS BILL CREATES A POLICY
FRAMEWORK TO CAPTURE IT AND USE
IT TO HELP REPLACE DIESEL
ENGINES AND HEAVY TRUCKS AND
MACHINERY.
IT AUTHORIZES OUR INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS AND CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION FUELS LIKE
HYDROGEN OR WES WASTE NOTHING.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS A
LANDMARK PROPOSAL.
BUT ALSO MEASURED.
IT'S A MEASURED APPROACH THAT
ENSURES WE HAVE FLEXIBLE AND
RELIABLE GRIT.
NOW BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE PRIVATELY OWNED INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AS WELL AS THE
MUNICIPAL A UTILITIES TO FIX AS
MANY OF THE CONCERNS AS
POSSIBLE.
HAVE BEEN WORKING IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THESE GROUPS
TO MEND THE BILL AND FIND
AGREEMENT THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO.
WITH WORKING WITH OUR CHAIRMAN
HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY
SIMILAR --
GOALS ON THE ISSUE OF ENERGY
CLEAN ENERGY IN THE WILL DO SO
OVER THE SUMMER BREAK. ONE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMEDIAN ELSE'S SECTION FIVE A
BOTTOM OF PAGE THREE WAS
DESIGNED TO AVOID DIS
INCENTIVIZING AYE YOU USE AND
PEEL USE FROM CONVERTING.
A BUILDINGS IMPORTS FROM FOSSIL
FUELS TO ELECTRICITY.
AS NOTED CORRECTLY IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT AMENDMENT WAS NOT
AS CLEARLY DRAFTED AT THE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN AND AS A RESULT HAS
CREATED SOME CONTROVERSY
[inaudible]
NO DOUBT.
IN DO INTO AND INTRUSIVE
REDUCING THAT CONTROVERSY AT
THIS JUNCTURE I LIKE TO GO WITH
THE CHAIRS PERMISSION TO OFFER
AND AUTHORS AMENDMENT TO REMOVE
THAT AMENDMENTS.
BY DELETING SECTION TWO OF THIS
BILL.
HOWEVER THAT BEING SAID A MISTER
CHAIR THAT I PLAN TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP WORKING ON THAT ISSUE WITH
THE P. O. USE PACIFIC LEAD THE
MUNIS -- BUT
WILL DO SO ARE SEPARATE FROM
THIS MEASURE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE PROCESS --
AND HOW WE WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE SURE WE
GET THIS RIGHT WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR --
MISTER VICE CHAIR I AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR YOUR DUE DILIGENCE AND FOR
YOUR HARD WORK AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR A LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE THAT AND I WERE AS YOU
DESCRIBE THE AUTHORS AMENDMENT
IT WOULD BE
IN LIEU OF AMENDMENT NUMBER FIVE
A STRIKE SECTION TWO IN THE BILL
IN ITS ENTIRETY.
THAT WOULD BE PAGE FOUR LINE.
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY THREE AND ON
PAGE FIVE LINES.
ONE TO TWENTY I'M GOING TO
FOLLOW YOUR LEAD ON THAT --
BIG I DON'T HAVE THE BILL IN
FRONT OF ME WHEN I'M GONNA
FOLLOW IT AS IT IS SAYING THAT
AS THE HEARING CONTINUES YOU CAN
JUST REFLECT ON IT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S YOU ARE CORRECT YOUR
QUICKNESS A CHAIR.
OF WILL HEAR YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RECESS
ARE DEALS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BILLION CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL --
AS YOU KNOW IN THIS COMMITTEE
NOTES ARE MEMBERS ARE BUILDING
RENEWABLE ENERGY POWER PLANTS OF
SOLAR WIND GEOTHERMAL AND THE
RAPTURE FITS FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCIES CREATED THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING
UNION JOBS.
IN ADDITION TO THE CLIMATE AND
AIR QUALITY BENEFITS PREVIOUS
PROGRAMS.
COUNTLESS JOB BENEFITS HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED TO SOME OF THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED REGIONS OF OUR
STATE.
AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY BUT BECAUSE OF THESE
SOLAR PLANTS AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS.
A LOT OF KIDS FROM THOSE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN NOW EARNING
DECENT WAGES.
WITH ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND PENSION BENEFITS
AS WELL.
THESE KIDS ACTUALLY MAY NOT HAVE
HAD OTHER OPPORTUNITIES BUT
THESE ARE ENTRY LEVEL JOBS WHERE
DALY TRISH AND AN OPERATING
ENGINEER AN IRON WORKER.
COUNTLESS OTHER TRAITS LIKE SAP
THEM PUT THEM ON RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS AND THEN THEY'RE
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE HOSPITALS
BRIDGES.
OUGHT TO NAME A FEW.
ON THE BUILDING TRADES HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING COMMUNITY
BENEFIT AGREEMENTS ON SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT NINETEEN
MILLION HOURS OF CONSTRUCTION
FOR BUILDING TRADES WORKERS
CALIFORNIA JOBS.
INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES IN AREAS THAT PERHAPS
THERE'S GOING TO BE MORE GROWTH
BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND SO THESE ARE OPPORTUNITIES I
CREATE.
GREAT DEVELOPMENT.
AND THESE ARE NOT ONLY FOR
JOURNEY PERSON SIR FOR
APPRENTICES AS WELL AND WITH
ACCESS TO MIDDLE CLASS CAREERS.
BUT THE CURRENT TARGETS FOR THE
RP ES ARE ARE MATT --
THEY'RE BASICALLY HITTING THEIR
TARGET.
WE COULD OBTAIN HIGHER WE
BELIEVE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
STRONGLY SUPPORTING SP --
ONE HUNDRED WERE ALREADY SEEING
CONSTRUCTION SLOWED DOWN BECAUSE
MAJOR UTILITIES ALREADY HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED TO MEET THE 50%.
TO KEEP PEOPLE WORKING HELP MEET
OUR TWENTY THIRTY CLIMATE GOALS
WE SHOULD INCREASE THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET 260%.
THE INDUSTRY IS READY AND
WAITING THE WORKFORCE IS READY
AND WAITING AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE AT YOUR SPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND NOT TOUGH WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
AND I KNOW HE AND HERE WITH A A
VERY BROAD COALITION OF
COMMUNITY FAITH BASED GROUPS --
LABOR OF PARTNERS BUSINESS AND
HEALTH OF GROUPS TO SUPPORT SB
--
ONE HUNDRED HERB JUST BEFORE THE
HEARING WE DELIVERED OVER --
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND NAMES AND
PETITIONS FROM EVERY SINGLE
DISTRICT IN THE STATE AND RTC
ALONE HAD OVER SEVEN THOUSAND OF
OUR MEMBERS AND ACTIVISTS
CONTACT.
EVERY LEGISLATOR IN IN SAY TO TO
SUPPORT SP.
ONE HUNDRED BECAUSE A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE IS REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH.
I IT IT'S VERY I JUST WANT TO
REFLECT ON OF THE CONSENSUS THAT
HAS EMERGED AROUND.
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING CLEAN
ENERGY AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT THAT BRINGS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
I'M ALWAYS BEEN VERY BULLISH ON
CALIFORNIA AND WE CANNOT
CERTAINLY CANNOT LET THE STATE
OF HAWAII BEAT US --
WHEN IT COMES TO OTHER THEIR
CLEAN ENERGY TARGETS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY BEEN --
MEETING ARE CLEAN ENERGY TARGETS
ESSAYS ARE SAID AND WE CAN DO
BETTER AND WE ARE ON TRACK AND I
WE ARE QUITE CONFIDENT THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO MEET THESE
AMBITIOUS TARGETS.
AND IT HELPS PROVIDE MARKET
CERTAINTY WHEN THE WHEN THESE
TARGETS ARE IN PLACE AND AS YOU
KNOW.
THE CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY TARGETS
ARE GONNA TAKE EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO MEET.
AND IT'S A COMBINATION OF
INCENTIVES REGULATIONS TARGETS
AND OTHERS THAT ARE ALL HAVE TO
WORK TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN
MEET THESE.
TARDY'S I ARE AMBITIOUS GOALS
BECAUSE AS WE SEE ALL MY EYES
ARE RECUPERATING RIGHT NOW FROM
HAVING DRIVEN JUST DRIVEN
THROUGH THE FIRE I MUST SAY --
AND THE MOST RECENT A SCIENTIFIC
REPORTS YOU KNOW THAT POLLS ARE
MELTING FASTER THAN WE THOUGHT
THEY THEN THE SCIENTISTS
PREDICTED THEY WOULD SO WE DON'T
HAVE.
AND ANY TIME TO LOSE ON THIS AND
THE WAY THINGS ARE RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA AND WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS STATES IS REALLY WHERE
THE ACTION IS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GETTING HELP.
FROM.
BACK EAST AT THIS POINT AND THE
CAPITAL SO I WANTED TO JUST
REALLY REAFFIRMED.
THE STRONG --
CONSENSUS THAT EXISTS TO THE
OUTPUT THESE TARGETS IN PLACE
AND TO MOVE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE ND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SP ONE HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
OKAY Y. DON'T WE BECAUSE LOOK TO
TAKE --
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC --
WHO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BUT WE
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION --
SO YOU JUST HAD ENOUGH TIME TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
MONNING IS THE CHAIR.
MORNING MEMBERS JUST A LOT OF
POP OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH DIRECTORS AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST CODE
COALITION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WHICH I ABOUT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SILENCE SALAS POTTER HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE MITCHELL MAP IS
SERIOUS AND SOME GENERATION
ADVISORS AND SUPPORT.
ERICA MARTINEZ SOME BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL MALES ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAUCUS
HERE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING UNA SORRY AMY
HINDSIGHT I'M AMOM AND WITH THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES CW A LOCAL
NINETY ONE NINETEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR HOLDEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH LESLIE AND I AM A
MOM OF AN EIGHT YEAR OLD AND I'M
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE HEARING ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT OF SB ONE HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME THAT HE
THOUGHT SAID AM I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO TEENAGE BOYS I'M WITH
MOTHERS OUT FRONT AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED GOOD MORNING CAROL
WARREN ST JAMES PARISH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DOCTOR CAROL WE'D.
WITH CONTRA COSTA CLEAN ENERGY
ALLIANCE I ASK FOR YOUR UPS VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
LAUREN EACH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINE HOOKS
AND I'M.
HERE I'M REPRESENTING I'M I'M
GRANDMOTHER AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING MOTHERS AND
GRANDMOTHERS AND GRANDFATHERS AT
SONOMA COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL S. B. ONE HUNDRED
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU.
DARCY SWEENEY M. REPRESENTING
THREE FIFTY CINEMA AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
SONNY GALBRAITH THREE FIFTY
SEVEN CISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE R. L. MILLER CLIMATE HAWKS
VOTE ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WHICH STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AND HAS ENDORSED IT THANK
YOU.
AND JEAN CROSLEY SIERRA CLUB IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SARAH COOPER FROM
BERKELEY AND REPRESENTING
CONGREGATION BETH EL IN BERKELEY
INDIVISIBLE BERKELEY THANK YOU.
FOR HOPEFULLY FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TINA GALLAGHER AND TAILOR ME YE
PRIME AT THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND SMELL OFF WITH
VOTE SOLAR WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
MADELINE STANNO WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LYNETTE THERE WITH A YELLOW
INTERFAITH ALLIANCE FOR CLIMATE
JUSTICE.
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOULD OCCUR
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THREE
FIFTY RIVERSIDE IN SOCAL THREE
FIFTY CLIMATE ACTION THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHARITY IS REPRESENTING OFFICER
REPAIR ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
CAITLYN KALUA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE
IN HERE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSON OBVIOUSLY SEAN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BRIAN
WHITE HERE WE HAVE TO RETURN
ENERGY IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL.
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF OF NOT
ALL THIS DATA TECHNOLOGIES SPORT
BANG.
EILEEN TOLD ROBBIE HALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO ASTHMA TASK FORCE
FRESNO MADERA MEDICAL SOCIETY
AND THE MERCED MARIPOSA COUNTY
ASTHMA COALITION THANK YOU.
MORNING LAURA WAS LYNN FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WILL BEAR WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALSO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
THREAT SIX SIDEY.
IN THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ALSO STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JUDY POPE WITH WELLSTONE
DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL CLUB IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARC ALL FEEL WITH
CITIZENS CLIMATE LOBBY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED JACK* OF ALSO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
RUBY MCDONALD'S OF LEGAL WITHIN
BORDERS TO WALL BERKELEY ALL BUT
THE AND EMERYVILLE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ROBERT MCDONALD THE SAME PLUS
UNION OF CONCERNED SUPPORT OR
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS STRONG
SUPPORT.
DEBRA FILLED A ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY SOUTH BAY LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BETSY THAGGARD ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH THREE FIFTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT KUBRICK REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
CENTER OF REFORM JUDAISM
REPRESENTING CONGREGATIONS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND ALSO REPRESENTING MY OWN
CONGREGATION TEMPLE BETH EL AN
APT US CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SP ONE HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
BARBARA RYAN ON BEHALF OF A
THOUSAND GRANDMOTHERS AND
NETWORK OF ELDER WOMEN WHO
BELIEVE IN THINKING DOWN SEVEN
GENERATIONS AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MORNING.
MARY KAY BENSON CHICO THREE
FIFTY AN OIL MONEY OUT IN
SUPPORT.
VANESSA VEGA WITH GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND WE THINK
LAURA FRIEDMAN FOR HER SUPPORT
ON THE SPELL.
KEVIN ENDS CHO REPRESENTING THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC POLICY
AND THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
JEWISH WOMEN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH WAS SANSKI YOLO MOVE
ON AND START SIERRA CLUB --
SOLANO GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK.
ELLEN GOOD IS STILL FROM PHIL
TINGS DISTRICT REPRESENTING ALL
OF THE PEOPLE ON MY BLOCK WHO
ARE BELOW SEA LEVEL.
IN SUPPORT.
IN ABOUT HIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARMS JUST SCIENCE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE EVAN
MENTEN WITH CALIFORNIA VOICES
FOR PROGRESS WE REPRESENT
BUSINESS OWNERS ENTREPRENEURS
INVESTORS AND FLANK THEIR PACE
IT'S A PRIORITY BILL BRYSON WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
JOHN WHITE WITH CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN THAT SUPPORT.
SHE ENTITY WITH LARGE COUNSELOR
SUSPICION STRONG SUPPORT.
DO ANY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION ON THE CALIFORNIA
STORAGE AND STE --
SOLAR ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN LEE ROSENBERG A SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
SQUARE.
ERNEST SHAKE A COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF BGA
RELAXING SPORT.
DATE GARCIA WITH CHICO THREE
FIFTY AND FRACTURING BUTTE
COUNTY STRONG SUPPORT.
RECOVERED A MEMBER OF STRAWBERRY
CREEK QUAKERS MEETING IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND THAT THE
PEACE EARTH CARE AND SOCIAL
WITNESS COMMITTEE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JERRY ELEVEN BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
MOVED TO SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENT TAKEN THIS MORNING AND
WE ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE IN
THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
LANGUAGE LIKE FROM AB TWO TWO O.
EIGHT THAT WOULD ENSURE.
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF IN STATE
RENEWABLE RESOURCES AS WE MOVE
TOWARD A BEYOND 60% THANK YOU.
KELLY BOY WITH CALIFORNIA LOW
CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY COALITION
ALSO IN SUPPORT AND ECHOING A
JULIUS COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO THANK YOU.
YES SIR WILLIAM BYNUM FROM --
ORVILLE REPRESENTING SAVE
OROVILLE TREES AND SUPPORT.
LABOR NOW WHAT THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH A CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN JONES REPRESENTING THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JAMIE MINOR BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
IN THE SPORT.
CATHERINE BRANDENBURG ON BEHALF
OF CINEMA CLEAN POWER IN
SUPPORT.
AND PONZI OVER CHICO THREE FIFTY
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING CARL ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAN MEN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
PROFESSOR CLEAR BROWN
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO THREE
FIFTY AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
LINDA HUTCHINS KNOWLES WITH SAN
JOSE FRIENDS MEETING IN SAN JOSE
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JUSTIN KATZ BROWN WITH THREE
FIFTIES PAY.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M RIGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLAYING
TO ALL THAT SERVING ENTITIES.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY TO ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR AND HIS STAFF AND WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE WITH THEM MONTHS
REMAINING ISSUES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CARE ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF PASADENA WE ALSO
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF AMEND A
POSITION WE ARE VERY COMMITTED
TO AGGRESSIVELY GOING AFTER
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN THE FUTURE.
WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT SOME
TRANSMISSION CONSTRAINTS ISSUES
AND ALSO SOME STRANDED ASSETS
AND THOSE POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON A
REPAIRS.
MUNICH A POOR COALITION FOR ANY
OF OUR NATURAL GAS AYE WE
APPRECIATE THE AMEND THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE SECTION.
TO THE REASON WAS PROBLEMATIC
FOR INITIATION WAS THAT.
IF I DID SORRY IF.
USE YOUR STATE OF A UNIT THAT GO
INTO RICHEST WE'D LIKE TO URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER FUEL
NEUTRALITY WHEN THEY LOOK AT
REPLACEMENT LANGUAGE FOR THAT'S
ACTION IF THEY DO AND APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH DOCTOR THINK OF BOB
MICHEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA.
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT.
CHINA PRICE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
DEVICE CUFF WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GEORGIANA HIS HONOR IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
LINDA FLOWER ON HIGHLY
SUPPORTIVE OF A BILL OF CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT AND PROTECT OUR
WINTERS.
CHRYSALIS MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY
MARIN IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN STEVENS SENATE CALIFORNIA
INTERFAITH POWER AND LIGHT IN
OUR SEVEN HUNDRED RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE MEMBERS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JOHN WHEELER BERKELEY
RESIDENT CONCERNED CITIZEN AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
AMBER BLIXT FOR THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BRUCE YOU'RE BELTRAN SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF YOU SEE ESPY'S CAMPUS
DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORT.
RYAN ON BEHALF OF CALPERS.
FOR DAVID YES WAS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA 1100% CLEAN ENERGY
COALITION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DUCK
HOUSTON REPRESENTING THE SIERRA
BUSINESS COUNCIL WE TOUR IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MERCED MANNING ON BEHALF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER IN SUPPORT.
IN THE BOTTOM HALF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY BY ALL VERGE A
CONCERNS ARE NOT YET BEEN
ADDRESSED WE LOOK FOR DIRECT THE
OFF OFFICE YOU.
A THANK YOU TO ALL OF THOSE
WHO'VE SPOKEN OUT AND GIVING US
YOUR YOUR SUPPORTED POSITIONS
NOW WE WILL.
RECEIVE THE COMMITTEE WILL HEAR
FROM.
ANYONE WHO'S HERE AS A WITNESS.
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
.
ONE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LEAH
SILVERTHORNE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CAL CHAMBER OPPOSES SP ONE
HUNDRED BECAUSE IT CREATES
UNCERTAINTY FOR BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE AND DOES THREATEN TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE ENERGY
COSTS BY CREATING AN AMBIGUOUS
ZERO CARBON POLICY.
THAT INTERFERES WITH ONGOING
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
JUST IMPLEMENTED JUST A FEW
YEARS.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ALREADY PAY
AMONG THE HIGHEST PER KILOWATT
HOURS IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIAL RATE PLATE
PAYERS PAY A PREMIUM OF 68% OVER
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FARMING IN
FOOD PRINT PROCESSING COMPANIES
ALSO PAY A SIMILAR PROGRAM.
EVERY TIME A NEW ENERGY SCHEME
IS PUT INTO PLACE THESE PREMIUMS
DO INCREASE THREATENING GOOD
PAYING JOBS THREATEN GOOD PAYING
INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL JOBS
ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS ACROSS
THE STATE.
WELL THIS ME FEEL LIKE
INCREMENTAL CHANGE AT SOME POINT
THREE DOT ENSURE A THOUGHTFUL
MEASURED AND FLEXIBLE APPROACH
TO MEDIA CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS WE
WILL REACH A TIPPING POINT.
PUSHING OUT CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND THOSE GOOD PAYING
JOBS TO OTHER STATES.
IT'S NOT REALISTIC TO BELIEVE
THAT GREEN ENERGY JOBS CAN
REPLACE ALL INDUSTRIAL MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS ACROSS ALL SECTORS
ACROSS ALL THE STATE.
THE INCREMENTAL COST INCREASE
ALONE FROM THIS ADDITIONAL RPF
SCHOOL IS ESTIMATED TO COST THE
STATE AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
ADDITIONAL LOSS OF PROPERTY TAX
INCOME FROM.
SHUTTING DOWN EVENTUAL NATURAL
GAS FACILITIES OWNED BY STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH ARE
USED TO FUND.
BASIC RESOURCES SUCH AS POLICE
AND FIRE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THIS LEGISLATURE WISELY ENACTED
MEASURED LAWS SUCH AS A. B. THE
NINETY EIGHT WHICH DID ALLOW FOR
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING AND
WELL DESIGNED CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY.
ENERGY PRODUCERS HAVE RESPONDED
IN A MEETING THOSE GOALS.
THROWING AMIRI ADDED NEW
PROCUREMENT MANDATES INCREASE
OUR PS GOALS AND ACCELERATED
TIME LINES AMIR TWO YEARS LATER
THROWS A WRENCH IN THAT PROCESS.
IT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR LONG TERM
PLANNING NECESSARY BRING ONLINE
NEW TECHNOLOGY.
ENSURE GREATER RELIABILITY AND
KEEP READ RATES AT A LEVEL THAT
CAN ST STE CONTINUE GROW FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS DIFFERENT
SECTORS.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY PREMATURE
LET'S ALLOW THE PROCESS STARTED
UNDER S. B. THIRTY TWO IN EACH
THREE NINETY EIGHT CONTINUE AND
EVALUATE THE MILESTONES AS HE
REACHED OUT. FOR THESE REASONS
CAL CHAMBER WOULD ASK FOR A
NOTE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VALERIE
TRAIL OF LAJOS SPECIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY --
RESPECTFULLY --
OPPOSE I'M S. B..
ONE HUNDRED P. GENE --
IS VERY COMMITTED [inaudible]
TO WE SUPPORTED S. B. --
THREE FIFTY SUPPORTED --
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL TO GET 240%
REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GASES BY
[inaudible]
TWENTY AT THIRTY AS WE SAID LAST
YEAR -- WE
CAN SUPPORT.
AND WE SAID MULTIPLE TIMES ON IN
THE SPELL WE CAN SUPPORT TO ADD
THE 60% ACCELERATION --
OF OF OUR PS --
TO TWENTY THIRTY IF THOSE AS
LONG AS ALL THE PROGRAM RULES
STATE STAY IN PLACE THAT WE SO
HEAVILY DEBATED IN.
S. B. [inaudible]
THREE FIFTY ON HOWEVER.
MOVING BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY RPG
DETAILS AT THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROPERLY PROTECT CUSTOMERS FROM
ON HIGH COSTS --
THE BILL DOES NOT DEFINE AND
REASONABLE OR OR ADD WHAT I DO
UNREASONABLE BILL A RATE IMPACT
WOULD BE.
ON AND WE DON'T SEE A PROPER
PROTECTION WHERE POST.
TWENTY THIRTY ABOUT WHAT WE'D
RATHER SEE IS A LOOK AT ALL
SECTORS WITH THEIR COSTS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS ARE
PER TON AND LOOK AT IT COMPARED
TO WHAT THE ELECTRIC SECTORS
BEING ASKED --
TO IT COULD BE ASTARTE SHOULDER
--
UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK --
FURTHERMORE --
AS WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR A LONG TIME IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE CURRENT.
POWER CHARGING DIFFERENT
ADJUSTMENT STILL HAS YET TO BE
REFORMED AND WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM ARE REGULATED THE PC IS
THAT AS THE CUST CUSTOMERS ARE
DEPARTING OUR LOAD --
THOSE DEPARTING CUSTOMERS ARE
PAYING ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR AND THAT STILL YET
ON TV OUTPERFORMED.
THERE IS THEIR LACK --
EQUAL PROTECTION OF OF ALL
CUSTOMERS IN THIS BILL IN THE
FORM OF EQUAL RULES FOR ALL OF
THE VOTES SERVING WE HAVE A
GROWING FRAGMENTED.
MARKET THIS IS SOMETHING A
PRINCIPLE THAT P. JEANNIE ADAM
AND THE AND THE OTHER YOU --
TO I'LL USE A FAST --
FOR FOR MANY MANY MANY YEARS
OVER A DECADE AND RIGHT NOW THE
WAY WE READ THE LANGUAGE IT
SIMPLY INSURES THAT CAR DOES NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO CHANGE.
OUR PS RULES --
WHICH IS A FINE AMENDMENT BUT
DOESN'T HAVE EQUAL PROTECTION --
ARE EQUAL ON RULES AND FOR ALL
THAT SERVING IT TO TEASE UNDER
THIS FRAMEWORK --
FINALLY I GUESS I WOULD SAY THAT
--
WE ARE CURRENTLY UNDER A A VERY
UNCERTAIN REGULATORY LEGAL FRAME
LEGAL TYING UP BUT BEING FACED
BY THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND BY
THIS I MEAN THE NEW NORMAL THAT
WERE UNDER --
WE HAVE A AND THIS IS THE
WILDFIRE ISSUE.
RIGHT NOW --
THE ELECTRIC AT THAT THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES --
ARE PLAGUED BY REGULATORY
UNCERTAINTY IT'S CHALLENGING TO
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF THE
UTILITIES.
DRIVING UP THE COST OF CAPITAL
IN HER WILL RESULT IN HIGHER
CUSTOMER BILLS --
BESIDES THAT UNCERTAINTY WE HAD
A JOINT HEARING YESTERDAY WHERE
WE HEARD ABOUT OTHER CHALLENGES
IF WE PEEL BACK.
THE CURTAIN AND SEE WHAT THE
ELECTRICITY MARKET FACES IN
TERMS OF RESOURCE ADEQUACY --
UNSPECIFIED RESOURCES HOW ARE WE
GONNA TRACK ARE GREENHOUSE GASES
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET IN ORDER.
AND PGD FEELS THAT WE SHOULD.
TAKE A MOMENT TO PAUSE --
RECONCILE THESE POLICY
UNCERTAINTIES BEFORE WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT WOULD HELP US FOR
NO VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
POKER DORO ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION TO REPRESENT THE
STATE'S.
LEADING FARMING OPERATIONS A
NUMBER OF FOOD PROCESSORS AND AG
WATER AGENCIES.
I'M I JUST WANNA SUMMARIZE WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM THE FIRST TWO
WITNESSES I THINK WHAT YOU HEARD
WAS LAUDABLE GOAL.
NOT NOW.
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE NOT
NOW CLEARLY SINCE OUR RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD AND ARE
CLIMATE POLICY PROGRAMS.
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN ELECTRIC
RATES.
UP FOR AGRICULTURE LIKE THE
MANUFACTURING COMMERCIAL SECTORS
WERE PAYING FAR MORE THAN OUR
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER STATES IN
OUR COMPETITION VOTE NATIONALLY.
AND INTERNATIONALLY MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO CONTINUE ON
DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE --
THAT'S GETTING LAYERED ON IN
LAYERED ON AND LAYERED ON BY ALL
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RENEWABLE
ENERGIES OF LAUDABLE GOAL
FARMERS ARE IMPLEMENTING
RENEWABLE ENERGY ON THEIR FARMS
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
WE'RE SEEING SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN SOLAR.
AYE ENERGY INSTALLATIONS ON VOTE
DAIRIES AND FARMING OPERATIONS
IN THE STATE BUT WE DO NEED TO
TAKE A PAUSE AND TAKE A TIME OUT
--
THE WILDFIRE ISSUE IN AND OF
ITSELF IT'S GOING TO REPRESENT
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASES FOR
CUSTOMERS AS PJ NAY SEEKS TO I
KERATITIS.
THE LIABILITY FROM LAST YEAR'S
FIRES THAT ALONE COULD ADD AS
MUCH TO THE PENNY A KILOWATT
HOUR TWO ELECTRIC RATES FOR
LARGE.
BUSINESS CUSTOMERS IN THE STATE.
WE NEED TO BE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT GOING FORWARD WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO HARDEN OUR SYSTEM
TO PREVENT.
FORCE FIRES THAT'S GONNA COME AT
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS IN THE STATE --
IF WE LOOK TO THE GAS SECTOR OF
THOSE RATE INCREASES HAVE BEEN
2240% AS WE DEALT WITH SAN BRUNO
AND PGD SERVICE TERRITORY AND
40% RATE INCREASE PROPOSED BY
THE GAS COMPANY --
IT AS A RESULT OF RELEASE OF
CANYON SO THERE'S A LOT MORE
RATE INCREASES COMING FOR
IMPLEMENTING STORAGE MANDATES
WE'VE GOT PENDING LEGISLATION.
TO DOUBLE THAT STORAGE MANDATE
THAT STORAGE COMES AT
SIGNIFICANT COST.
THE CPUC JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO --
BUT APPROVED SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ROUGHLY OF
ELECTRICAL BE VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ALL GETS
RATE BASED IT ADDS TO CONSUMER
COSTS IT'S PART OF OUR CLIMB
POLICIES IN THE STATE.
SO WHERE TO A CRITICAL POINT IF
THIS.
CONTINUES --
TO MANDATE AFTER MANDATE
CONTINUES TO ADD THAT THESE
COSTS WE'RE GOING TO START
LOSING BUSINESSES I RECOGNIZE
JOBS CAN BE CREATED BY SOLAR
DEVELOPMENT.
WONDERFUL BUT YOU NEED TO START
CALCULATING THE JOBS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE LOST IN THIS STATE.
AS WE CONTINUE THIS INCREASING
PUSH.
TOWARDS ADDITIONAL MANDATES.
WE'RE DOING GREAT IN THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS NOT NEEDED AT THIS
TIME AND WE NEED TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO STEP BACK.
IT'S NOT JUST THE UNCERTAINTY OF
WILD FIRES WHO SERVING WHO AND I
THINK THE OTHER BIG THEME IN
YESTERDAY'S.
HEARING WAS --
YOU'VE GOT A COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION GOT DIRECT ACCESS
AND LOAD SERVING ENTITIES YOU
GOT THE ABILITIES.
WHOSE PROCURING FOR WHOM AT THIS
POINT WE NEED TO SOLVE THAT
QUESTION WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
INVERSE CONDEMNATION MOVING
FORWARD BECAUSE THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE.
NOT JUST FOR THE UTILITIES BUT
FRANKLY FOR RATEPAYERS WAR WE'RE
GONNA BE SECURITIZED AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
IN ADDITIONAL RATES FOR
CUSTOMERS BECAUSE WILD FIRES
AGAIN TO CONTINUE WITH THEIR
CONTINUED TO BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WE GOT A LOT OF BIG ISSUES ON
THE ENERGY FRONT THAT NEED TO
GET RESOLVED BEFORE WE TAKE THIS
STEP.
OF MOVING TO A 100% CLEAN ENERGY
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WILL NOW HERE JUST
STAY -- NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
AND RECOGNIZE IN THE COMMENTS
ORGAN MADE IN OPPOSITION THAT
YOU'RE ALIGN YOURSELF WITH.
BUT I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M SORRY YOU'RE YOU'RE
ONE OF THE OKAY.
IF JUST TWO MINUTES I WILL I'LL
TAKE ONE AND TWO ONE HEARD A
MICHAEL SHAW CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ECHO THE COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES
ARE VERY TESTIFIED.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ONE THING
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON RELIABILITY.
HOW THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT TODAY
WE SEE WITH THE?
INFAMOUS TUCKER --
AND THE RAMP AND IT OCCURS IN
THE EVENING HOURS --
THE POTENTIAL FOR PUSHING THE
LADY OR THE ROLE AT RENEWABLES
HIGHER AND HIGHER --
CREATES ADDITIONAL RELIABILITY
ISSUES WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION AT THIS POINT TIME.
TECHNOLOGY IS CERTAINLY
ADVANCING WEEK KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
APPRECIATE --
THAT AND THEY THE THAT'S GOOD
SENATOR.
OF FORM PRO TEM'S --
EFFORTS TO TO PUSH THAT FORWARD
HOWEVER WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
IS APPROPRIATE TO GAMBLE A
CALIFORNIA'S --
ECONOMIC FUTURE ON THAT
PARTICULAR --
EXPECTATION THAT IT WILL HAPPEN
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN SO HAS
NOT OCCURRED SO WITH THAT I IN
THE COMMENTS HAD MADE FOR THAT
WE OPPOSE US TWO HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS NAME AND
AFFILIATION DENISOV MILLION
BEHALF THE ON THE LAST TO
CALIFORNIA GREENFIELD
ASSOCIATION CONFERENCE SEAT
ASSOCIATION THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
TRUE TO HIS ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
REPRESENTING THE FOOD PROCESSING
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
SEAN LEWIS THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING TWENTY THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POST.
MR TURN MEMBERS TRICIA GUARANTOR
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
DARREN ABOUT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON --
WE ECHO MANY THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE SAID.
TODAY WE OPPOSE.
CAN CAUSE WITH SENATOR GAS
ELECTRIC FOR THE REASONS STATED
IN OUR LETTER WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
CHEN MEMBERS WE CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN SIX PATROLMEN'S
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
KAREN MILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LORE
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIBRATION CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
DAIRIES IN CALIFORNIA CONGENERS
AND GROWERS ASSOCIATION WESTERN
AYE PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION.
AND VARIOUS OTHER AG INDUSTRIES
IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AND* ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES WHERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
REPORTER ZERO CARBON GOAL.
ARE ONLY ASK WOULD BE THAT WE
DEFINE WHAT'S YOUR CARBON IS OUR
FEAR IS THAT SIMILAR TO THE RP
HAS PROGRAM.
AN ARBITRARY LINE WOULD BE DRAWN
BETWEEN LARGE AND SMALL HYDRO
WHEN WE FEEL BOTH A RENEWABLE
BOTH SHOULD BE CONSIDERED ZERO
CARB [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHERS WHO ARE
PREPARED.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE FROM THE
PUBLIC OF SENATOR --
I THINK.
IT MIGHT BE IF WE COULD JUST IN
TERMS OF BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME.
OF ONE THAT IS ON MY MIND AS
IT'S ARE REFLECTED IN SOME OF
THE COMMENTS OF OPPOSITION.
AND TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY
OR LOCK INTO IT WHERE THE
UTILITIES HAVE SORT OF OUTLINED
--
SERVANT UNCERTAIN FUTURE IN
TERMS OF THE ISSUES THAT A REAL
TERMS OF WILDFIRES [inaudible]
YEAH.
PARTING CUSTOMERS AND WHAT THAT
REPRESENTS I KNOW THAT AND
YOU'RE PUTTING FORTH THIS BILL
THAT THOSE WERE NOT LOST ON YOU.
CAN YOU ADDRESS IT UP WE YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS AROUND OFF RAMPS
AND OTHER IDEAS THAT YOU THINK
MIGHT.
HELP ADDRESS WHICH YOU HEARD OF
CIRCUITS YOU THINK YOU'RE MUCH
I'M SECURING THE IS NOT LOST ON
ME OUT WE SEE --
THE RAVAGES OF OF OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WHAT IT'S DONE --
TO CALIFORNIA OUR SUMMERS ARE
ARE MUCH HARDER AND AS A RESULT
WE HAVE MORE FORCE FIRES WHICH A
HISTORICALLY WERE SEASONAL THERE
ARE NO LONGER SEASON OPENER
THERE YEAR ROUND WITH FIRES.
A BURNING AT A MUCH --
INTENSE RATES ARE.
IN NUDGES A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUT ALL OVER THE STE PRIVATELY
INVESTED --
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES ARE ARE
VERY CHALLENGE BECAUSE OF WHAT
HAS HAPPENED WITH REGARD TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THEY HAVE A LOT
OF ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE THEM
RIGHT NOW.
THE ROOM SURVIVABILITY --
AS THE AS INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
WITH REGARDS TO INVERSE
CONDEMNATION NE LIABILITY ISSUES
THAT WILL BE BEFORE ALL OF US
YOU KNOW SOON BOTH REPUBLICANS
AS WELL AS DEMOCRATS. TO MAKE A
DECISION WITH REGARDS TO
RATEPAYERS A CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
SHAREHOLDERS THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES USER LEGITIMATE --
ISSUES BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
DECISIVELY BECAUSE THIS IS GOING
TO PERHAPS BE THE NEW NEW WE
HAVE TO PLAN FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
AND SITTING ON THE SIDELINES AND
NOT ON THE FRONT LINES GOING TO
MAKE THE SITUATION ACTUALLY EVEN
WORSE UNLESS YOU HAVE VERY CLEAR
GOALS ARE STATED.
A VERY CLEAR MANDATE A PURCHASE
A VERY CLEAR PLAN NOT A MANDATE
AS WHAT'S PHRASE NOT ILLEGAL
MANDATE THAT HAS A CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL.
LAW PENALTY IF YOU WILL SENATE
BILL.
THREE FIFTY IT NEVER HAD A CIVIL
OR CRIMINAL --
PENALTY IF YOU WILL WITHOUT
REACHING THOSE TARGETS AND GOALS
LET ME TRY --
MISTER CHAIR TO SORT OF UNPACK
IF YOU WILL OF A LITTLE THE
COMETS ARE MADE BY.
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM UP
PACIFIC GAS --
TO NOT WANTING TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH STANDARDS --
WOULD GOALS OF A PLAN --
ON OUR PS UNLESS OTHER --
ENTITIES IN THIS CASE TELL PIPE
THE INVADERS THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR OR ALSO ARE TREATED WITH
THE SAME BRUSH.
ON THAT WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT
OF GOING TO WAR.
BUT WITH TWENTY NINE MILLION --
INDIVIDUAL --
DRIVERS IT IT IS NOT THAT THE
SAME ECONOMIC SCALE --
IT IS A VERY DIFFERENT METRIC.
YOU HAVE THREE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES PLUS A HANDFUL OF OF
MUNICIPALLY OWNED UTILITIES TO
OVERSEE THE GRID.
AND TO COMPARE THAT WITH.
TWENTY NINE MILLION INDIVIDUAL.
DRIVERS IN THE IN CALIFORNIA IS
IS APPLES AND ORANGES IS TO QUIT
WHEN UP SAYING THAT.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO SET
STANDARDS WITH THE NATURAL.
GAS.
PLANTS MELISSA YOU ACTUALLY GO
AFTER THE TWENTY NINE IN THE
MITCHELL A INDIVIDUAL DRIVERS --
I I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PERSPECTIVE BUT IT IT IT DOESN'T
WORK AYE IT IS APPLES AND
ORANGES RIGHT HERE ALL TIMIDLY.
UP WHEN I'M GONE YOU KNOW AFTER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN A THROUGH YOUR
LEADERSHIP YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR OF THE
UTILITIES --
COMEDIAN THE SENATE CENTER BEN
HUESO IN IN YOU KNOW LEADERS
HERE ALREADY.
MISS LAURA FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA DOCTOR
BILL QUIRK.
LET'S MEET BE UP TO YOU AND AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND THE COURAGE
DEBTS DEBTS DEMONSTRATED FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA MISS BURKE
AS WELL TO I KNOW SHE'S BEEN IN
THE CLIMATE SPACES WHILE.
TO UP WHAT STANDARD YOU SET
FORTH.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD POST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONE NINE A FEW OTHER --
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL LEAD IN
THIS SPACE WILL BE GONE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE STANDARDS
THAT YOU SET FOR TO WITH REGARDS
--
TO THE TAILPIPE INVADERS OF OF
CARBON DIOXIDE AND OTHER OTHER
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS ALTMAN IT'LL
BE UP TO YOUR LEADERSHIP TO SIDE
WHICH YOU WANT TO DO.
BUT YOU CAN'T EQUATE BECAUSE
IT'S APPLES AND ORANGES --
AND THAT'S THE POINT I WANT TO
MAKE HERE BECAUSE IT'S IT'S A
VERY DIFFERENT THAT IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT.
A METRIC DEL ALTOGETHER.
REGARDS TO EQUALIZE TREATMENT
BETWEEN THE TWO A ENTITIES IOUS
AND THE MO USE OBVIOUSLY THE
AMMO USE OUR ARE GOVERNED FROM
THE SEAT YOU SEE THE I USED THAT
THE P. UC.
THAT ULTIMATELY WHEN MAYBE IT'S
AN INDIVIDUAL.
SENATOR OR SOMETHING MEMBER HERE
--
AT AND IN THIS COMMITTEE IF THEY
WANT TO ENGAGE WITH THE I USE
AND DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE WHAT I
WOULD SAY THIS.
IF WE CAN WORK IT OUT ON THIS
MEASURE THAT THEN WE CAN'T WORK
IT OUT WITH THIS MEASURE YOU MAY
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD ON AN
ONGOING ISSUE AS STATED.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR TEN YEARS
CLOSE TO A DECADE TO EQUALIZE
TREATMENT BETWEEN THE MUNIZ.
AND THE I USE THIS IS NOT THE
SPACE OR THE VEHICLE TO TO DO SO
WE'RE TRYING.
TO THE AGREED TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITY WITH THE MUNICIPALLY
OWNED UTILITIES.
AND AND QUITE FRANKLY TO PUT
THIS INTO CONTEXT.
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES HAVE
NEVER REALLY BEEN THAT
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR PS.
THAT THE FIRST 00220% NOT THE
2233%.
AND THEY BECAME SUPPORTERS OF
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY IF YOU
WILL -- OF
WHAT WE INCENTIVIZE
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
THAT IS FOR THE BIRTH FOREVER.
OF FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
GETTING INTO THE MARKET ARENA TO
COMPETE WITH OTHER --
ENTITIES FOR MARKET SHARE IN
THIS CASE --
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION
CHARGING STATIONS THEN OBVIOUSLY
THEY BECAME A SUPPORTER OF
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SO
HISTORICALLY WHEN IT COMES FROM
YUBA PORTFOLIO STANDARDS.
THE I USE HAVE NOT BEEN STRONG
SUPPORTERS.
A I KNOW DOCTOR QUIRK AND DOCTOR
EGGMAN HAD A QUESTION CHEN.
AND SO WILL TURN TO DR QUIRK IN
THEM.
DOCTORED.
ALRIGHT SO THERE WERE NO A LOT
OF WHAT WAS BROUGHT UP HERE --
BY THE OPPOSITION.
WHAT'S THE CONCERN ABOUT PARTY
LOAD IN UNCERTAINTY.
HOWEVER SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO BROUGHT THIS UP.
EITHER ARE ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
BROUGHT THIS UP.
EITHER WERE IN FAVOR OF DIRECT
ACCESS A TO THE CHAMBER --
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS IN
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OR DIDN'T
OPPOSE IT NAMELY THE YACHT
UTILITIES.
IF THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
DEPARTING LOW AND FRANKLY I
THINK THEY SHOULD BE.
I BUT THEN WHY WEREN'T THEY
OPPOSED TO DIRECT ACCESS --
CAN'T [inaudible]
YOU CAN'T.
WANT DIRECT ACCESS AND THEN ALSO
SAY WE CAN'T DO A 100%
RENEWABLES.
BECAUSE WE'RE DEPARTING LOVED --
THAT'S THE FIRST CONTRADICTION I
SEE FROM THE OPPONENT SO LET ME
SAY I DID NOT DECIDE THEY WOULD
VOTE FOR THIS BILL UNTIL ABOUT
FIVE FIFTEEN LAST NIGHT.
AND I WAS WITH THE AUTHOR AT
THAT TIME WITH HIS STAFF.
AND AS PEOPLE COME TO MY OFFICE
FOR THE LAST --
YEAR AND A HALF WELL THESE BILLS
BEEN UP.
I'M I SAID LOOK I CAN ONLY VOTE
FOR THIS BILL IF THERE ARE
CERTAIN AMENDMENTS --
AND THOSE AMENDMENTS HAD BEEN
TAKEN AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR HIS STAFF.
AND THE VARIOUS COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR I THINK AMENDING THIS BILL
IN A WAY THAT IT IS NOW VERY
SUPPORTABLE.
THERE UNDOUBTEDLY ARE --
A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED ONE OF THEM HERE IS.
A WILDFIRE THE AND THE CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THAT --
WORKING TOGETHER WITH OTHERS
AROUND THIS TABLE.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT HASN'T
BEEN ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED.
BUT IT CAN'T BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THIS BELL.
ARE.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT WE NEED
--
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE SCHUMER
CHOICE ACT AGGREGATORS SHE CA
HAS.
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE FOR THE
STRANDED ASSETS.
AND SHOULD WE GET DIRECT ACCESS.
THROUGH WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY AGAIN PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
OF THE FOR THE STRANDED ASSETS.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE RIGHT NOW
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PROCEEDING IN FRONT OF THE P.
YOU SEE AT THIS MOMENT WILL
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AGAIN THIS BILL CANNOT SOLVE ALL
THE PROBLEMS.
UP ONE OF THE BIGGEST ARE
QUESTIONS THAT WAS RAISED HERE
WERE EQUAL RULES AND AND THE
QUESTION OF COST IN THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT?
IT DEFINITELY CONTAINS COST
CONTAINMENT UNLIKE SOME OF OUR
OTHER --
MANDATES AND LET ME READ THAT
SECTION.
OUR PAGE.
EIGHTEEN ARM SECTION
[inaudible]
SEE.
ARM AND G..
ARE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE PAGE I
THINK OF THIS IS PAGE.
TEN THE COMMISSION SHALL
ESTABLISH A LIMITATION FOR EACH
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION ON THE
PROCUREMENT EXPENDITURES. FOR
ALL RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCES
USED COMPLY WITH THE RENEWABLES
PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
LIMITATION SHALL BE SET EVAN LOW
LEVEL AND LISTEN CAREFULLY HERE
THAT PREVENTION DISPROPORTIONATE
RATE IMPACTS.
FURTHER IT SAYS IN SECTION DE.
IF THE COST LIMITATION FOR
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION IS
INSUFFICIENT.
SUPPORT THE PROJECTED COSTS OF
MEETING THE RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO
STANDARD REQUIREMENTS.
THE ELECTRICAL CORPORATION MAY
REFRAIN FROM ENTERING INTO NEW
CONTRACTS ARE CONSTRUCTING
FACILITIES.
BEYOND THE QUANTITY THAT CAN BE
PROCURED WITHIN THE LIMITATION
UNLESS ELIGIBLE RENEWABLE
RESOURCES.
CAN BE PROCURED WITHOUT
EXCEEDING A DEMAND AMISS
INCREASE IN RATES.
SO THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL.
AND IT IS IT REALLY BREAKS
GROUND COMPARED TO OTHER
MANDATES THAT WE'VE HAD.
FURTHER ON PAGE EIGHTEEN SO
THERE'S A QUESTION IS EVERYONE
HELD TO THE SAME STANDARDS.
AND WHAT WE SEEM FROM THE CCA'S
THE COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS
BEFORE.
IS THAT THEY WOULD GO AND
PURCHASE A RENEWAL BOWLER
AND THEN --
THE CUT PLACE THAT HAD --
THE LOUD THAT HAD GIVEN THEM
THAT ENERGY WITH THEN GO OUT AND
PURCHASE COAL.
WE HAVE TO PREVENT THAT AND
FORTUNATELY AGAIN I BELIEVE THIS
WAS TAKEN IN NATURAL RESOURCES
--
IT SAYS ON PAGE --
EIGHTEEN OF THE BILL --
LINE.
TWENTY NINE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
THIS POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA SHALL
NOT INCREASED CARBON EMISSIONS
ELSEWHERE IN THE REST YOUR GRID.
ENCHILADA ALLOW RESOURCE
SHUFFLING --
THAT WAS A KEY PART AGAIN OF MY
ACCEPTING THIS SO THERE BEEN
PEOPLE PUSHING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
I'VE SAID WITHOUT THE PROPER
AMENDMENTS I CANNOT ACCEPT THIS
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF TO THE
AMENDMENTS I'VE TAKEN THE I
THINK DO ANSWER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE OPPOSITION.
SO AGAIN I WOULD URGE US TO GO
FORWARD.
THE UTILITIES AND OTHERS DO FACE
CHALLENGES WELL BEYOND THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL.
FROM WILDFIRES AND OTHER ISSUES
WE NEED TO SOLVE THOSE BUT
THAT'S NOT WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL.
THIS BILL ANSWERS MY QUESTIONS
SETS A GOAL BUT NOT A GOAL THAT
WILL BE ACHIEVED IF THE COST IS
TOO HIGH.
AND WILL NOT BE ACHIEVED THROUGH
SHUFFLING THE DECK.
SO I AM FIRMLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE I THANK YOU.
I THINK DOCTOR QUIRK AS MAY HAVE
DONE A BETTER JOB WITH YOUR BILL
SENATORS AND SO SEVENTIES
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE SO MY MY REMARKS ARE
GOING TO BE DO YOU FEEL LIKE.
ABOUT LINUS.
WITHOUT DOCTOR QUIRK PRESENTED.
THAT THAT IS A SUFFICIENT
OFFRAMP. FOR THIS BILL IF COSTS
BECOME OUT OF CONTROL.
CONCERT MONSIEUR A FILAMENTOUS
--
AYE AYE WHAT OSES IT'S I DON'T
THINK I COULD EVER ARTICULATED
BETTER OF THEN THE DOCTOR QUIRK
OF QUITE FRANKLY.
NO WE HAD A VERY MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION WE WORKED VERY HARD
WITH REGARDS TO THE NECESSARY
OFF RAMPS IF YOU WILL IN THE
EVENTS -- IF
THE COST OF HAS AN IMPACT.
THE VOTE PRIVATE RESIDENCES OR
WHETHER THEY'RE BUSINESSES THAT
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO 41100% CLEAN
ENERGY IS TO GO.
TO CARBON FREE 1100% TO JUST
REACH A GOAL FOR THE GOAL SAKE
BUT RATHER WE TAKEN TO MINE.
YOU KNOW THE ECONOMY AND WHAT
THE NECESSARY OFF RAMPS ARE A TO
EXIT THE IF YOU WILL IF THINGS
THAT ARE UNFORESEEN CATASTROPHES
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHES ECONOMIC
DEPRESSION.
OR I SHOULD SAY --
IT'S JUST A DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT --
I WAS GONNA GO OVER IT THAT THAT
WAS YOUR RIG WHEN YOU ORIGINAL
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIR WHICH I
DID NOT.
A ANSWER ORIGINALLY BUT I'VE
SEEN MISTER A DOCTOR QUIRK
ANSWERED HIM [inaudible]
SO.
AS YOU SAY THAT ARE YOU SEEING
THIS AS A MANDATE OR PLANNING
GOAL POLITICAL.
WERE ALL CLEAR THAT'S THIS IS A
PLANNING ALL THIS IS OVER GOING
FOR BECAUSE OF THE BILL THREE
FIFTIES A PLANNING GOAL.
BECAUSE I WOULD SAY --
ONE OF THE THE ISSUES DOCTOR
QUICK BROUGHT UP WITH THAT --
PERHAPS A DISPARITY IN THE AT
OPPOSITION IS I THINK PEOPLE ARE
DOING.
KINDA RESPONDING SOMETIMES ARE
SCATTER SHOT APPROACH AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO COVER THEIR
BASES IF WE'RE GONNA GO DIRECT
ACCESS OF THAT'S GOOD LOWER
COSTS IN OF ME PROCUREMENT.
THERE OKAY WITH THAT BUT SO I
MEAN I I I JUST CONTINUE TO
CAUTION ALL OF US AS WE GO
FORWARD WE CAN'T BREATHE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THE SMOKE IS SO BAD
--
IN THE VALLEY A AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S FROM CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE ONGOING
ECONOMIES THAT WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF S. ARE GOING FORWARD
AND LARGE INVESTMENTS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE MADE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO I ALSO HEAR YOU SAYING IN
THIS THAT YOU ARE.
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE STRANDED ASSETS ISSUE THAT
COMES UP HAZARD UP A NEW GAS
PLANT IN MY DISTRICT THAT PEOPLE
STILL TRYING TO PAY.
FOR AND REPEAL HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT.
WHETHER WE GO DO WITHOUT OR NOT.
AND YOU ARE STILL COMMITTED TO
MOVE MOUSA THAN A MONTH SINCE I
AM A SICK MAN BUT BUT MISS AGAIN
DAILAMITE THIS EGGMAN DO THE
ANSWER IS IS IS YES I'M STRANDED
ASSETS HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN ISSUE
--
FOR MANY VIA AT THE TILL HE'S
FOR ALL PARTY REASONS YOU KNOW
WE WON'T GO INTO RIGHT NOW
SPECIFICALLY BUT A BC IT'S A
CONSUMER THE RAPE PARA WHO GET
STRANDED ALSO BY MANAGEMENT --
THAT'S WEIGHT MANAGEMENT
DECISION THAT ARE --
BICU USE OR I SHOULD SAY
SPECIFICALLY VALUES --
HAVE BEEN IMPACT --
AND SO THE ANSWER IS YES AND AND
YOUR RIGHTS WITH REGARDS TO THE
40% -- OUR
PS THEM THAT IS A PLANNING GO TO
SPANGLED BUT THERE WOULD DO AND
60% OF THE THE FORTY OR WE'RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING WITH THE WITH
THE CCA'S.
YOU'RE JUST SAYING WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE OUT OF THE LEGISLATORS TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT LATER.
THANK YOU MISS THE OLYMPICS
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF WAS
GALLAGHER SENATOR [inaudible]
MY I HAVE A QUESTION FIRST IS
THAT YOU KNOW IN THE BILL IT
TALKS ABOUT.
HAVING A BOUNCE IN BEING ABLE TO
USE ZERO CARBON RESOURCES IS THE
TERM THAT'S USED BUT THERE'S NO
DEFINITION.
IN THE BILL ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES --
WOULD THAT INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
NUCLEAR HYDRO ELECTRIC.
AND GEOTHERMAL --
ENERGY A IN THERE AND BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S NOT REALLY DEFINED IN IT
MAKES IT SEEM LIKE THAT MIGHT BE
LEFT UP TO THE IMPLEMENTING
AGENCIES --
AND FOR ME I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD TRY AND ESTABLISH THAT
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AS TO
WHAT CONSTITUTES --
ZERO CARBON RESOURCES OTHERWISE
IT CREATES UNCERTAINTY AND AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER THERE'S A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY OF WHAT THE
ZERO CARBON MARKET IS GONNA BE
INTO THE FUTURE --
SO EVER COULD YOU ANSWER IT
COULD YOU JUST I QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE GOING TO
DEFINE THAT TERM POOL IT
WOULDN'T INCLUDE THOSE TYPES OF
OF ENERGY IT WILL IT WILL SAY
THIS MISTER CALDERON THAT THAT'S
A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND I
WANTED TO PROVIDE.
OF FLEXIBILITY WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE ON THE
RISE AND AS LONG AS IT'S ZERO
CARBON THERE'S SOME --
POTENTIAL --
ENERGY RESOURCES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE --
WOULD DESERVE IN A STEP CITY
NUCLEAR FOR EXAMPLE COULD
NUCLEAR BE YOU KNOW CONCEIVABLY
PART OF THE OUR PS A IT COULD BE
NOW WAYS IT ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE.
NOW ISN'T IT THAT'S A QUESTION
--
THERE'S A MAKES SENSE --
WITH REGARDS TO PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE IT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS
OF DOLLARS AND CENTS --
I DON'T KNOW GIVEN THE FACT
THAT.
THAT WE HAVE TO PLANTS A A
DIABLO CANYON AS WELL AS SENATE
NO FREE AT SOMEBODY BEING
MOTHBALLED.
DIABLO CANYON ARE OWNED.
BY ANOTHER STRAND OF ACID YOU
KNOW BY OUT.
OF P. GENIE THAT'S BEING A
MOTHBALL THE PLAN TO BE
MOTHBALLED SO THAT IT'S OPEN
ENDED --
WANT TO KEEP IT OPEN AND IT WAS
ANY POTENTIAL NEW TECHNOLOGY
DEBTS CREATED.
NAM I IN THE FUTURE IT COULD BE
--
IS ON THAT ZERO CARBON VETO SO
OBVIOUSLY IT CLEARLY ALLOWS FOR
GEOTHERMAL AS WELL.
WHAT ABOUT HYDRO BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW AS YOU KNOW?
IS A LESSON THIRTY MEGAWATTS YOU
THAT CAN COUNT THAT OVER THIRTY
MEGAWATT HYDRO DOESN'T COUNT
TOWARDS IPS COULD IT BE INCLUDED
IN THE ZERO EMISSION.
OUR RESOURCE WE LOVE AND WE LEFT
BEHIND WHAT WE DO IT'S VERY
SPECIFICALLY WE ESTABLISH THIS
AND SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY TWO
IN THE 40% WE ALLOW FOR HYDRO --
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS NO --
BRANIEWO HYDRO PLANTS THAT THAT
WERE CREATED THAT THERE
ESTABLISH HYDRO PLANTS ARE
READY.
A IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT BE SEE
WE HAVE A P. JEANNIE PARTICULAR
--
OWNS A QUITE A FEW HAD TO PLANTS
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
SPECIFICALLY WE KNOW COMMUNITIES
OWN -- HYDRO
PLANTS THEY'RE ALLOWED IN THE
40% -- BITES --
THE CAVIAR HERE NOT SO MUCH TO
CARRY OUT BUT A KNOWN YOU
ESTABLISHED A HYDRO PLANTS --
CAN BE CREATED.
SO IF YOU HAVE A AS AN ASSET
THEY CAN BE --
THEY QUALIFY AS PART OF THAT OUR
PS NOW INCLUDE OVER THIRTY
MEGAWATT HIGH MISSING ANYTHING
GOING TO CHECK OUT LIMIT LET ME
GET THAT'S A PRE ABOUT REAL
QUICK WHAT THE COULD I I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTED.
THE 40% AT SENATOR POINTED OUT.
AND ANSWERING DOCTOR QUIRK AND
DOCTOR RECOMMENDS QUESTION IS
THAT IT IS PLANNING IT NOTHING
IN THIS BILL LOCKS PERSON AND HE
WENT ON A SPECIFIC SOURCES
BEYOND --
INTO THE 40% SORTS PLANNING ITS
ASPIRATIONAL TERMS OF WHAT THAT
ULTIMATELY BECOME SO THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THAT'S
GOING TO BE.
KIND OF PART OF FUTURE
CONVERSATION OF HOW THAT
DEMOCRATS IT IS DEFINED.
THE FUTURE CONVERSATION WITH A
LOANS EITHER WAY IN OTHER WORDS
THIS BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY.
ONCE.
THIRTY THREE AND THAT'S MY
CONCERN.
HOW IT MISTER GALLAGHER THROUGH
THE CHERUB ON SPECIFICALLY YOUR
YOUR QUESTION IS?
HOW DO WE IS A PART OF THE 40%
--
BUT YOU HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO ABOVE.
A THIRTY THREE OF MEGAWATT
EXISTING POINT EXIST HIGH
VISITING LARGELY DISABILITIES
THAT HAVE MORE THAN THIRTY
MEGAWATTS.
YEAH ARE THEY INCLUDED THAT'S
THAT'S THE QUESTIONING AND FIND
OUT THE ANSWER FOR YOU RIGHT NOW
REAL TIME SO GOING HOW CAN YOU
THE ANSWER SHOULD BE YES BUT I
WANT TO BE.
OF CERTAIN FOR YOU OFFER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BIG DEBTS THE ANSWER IS YES.
MATHIS WE WENT A LOT OF THE THE
ANSWER IS YES AND IN PART OF
WHAT AT THE CHAIRMAN JUST KIND
OF PLAN AS IT'S NOT REALLY.
SPELLED OUT AND AND AND PART OF
THIS WAS A CONVERSATION IS GOING
TO HAPPEN LATER --
I WANTED TO HAPPEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I DON'T WANT TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE AGENCIES YOU
KNOW AT THEIR WHIM WHAT THEY'D
DETERMINE CONSTITUTES.
A ZERO CARBON I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD DO THAT I MEAN ONE OF MY
CRITICISMS HAS BEEN THAT LOOK WE
NEED TO LEGISLATE WE NEED TO
FIND THESE THINGS.
HERE ARE NOT LEAVE THAT UP TO
SOMEBODY ELSE TO DO BECAUSE
WE'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
ACCOUNTABLE YOU KNOW TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT HOW THIS GETS
IMPLEMENTED HOW GETS.
AND TAKEN OUT AND SO.
THIS KNOW MY CONCERNS YOU KNOW
WITH THIS POLICY IS. ONE I FEEL
LIKE UP UNTIL THIS POINT.
WE TALK ABOUT OF RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD FOR THE
DOESN'T SEEM TOO MUCH OF A
PORTFOLIO LARGELY IT HAS BEEN.
SOLAR AND WIND --
SOME GEOTHERMAL WHERE WE CAN DO
THAT BUT IT'S BEEN LIMITED.
AND WE HAEN'T REALLY OPENED UP
THAT THERE'S NOT A DIVERSE
PORTFOLIO THE CAN HELP US.
YOU ACTUALLY ACTUALLY GET TO A
HIGHER LEVEL OF RENEWAL BOARD.
OF BEING USE HYDRO IS RENEWABLE
--
RESOURCE IS A RENEWABLE POWER
RESOURCE THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE SHOULD BE
UTILIZING. TO REACH THAT NON SO.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PORTFOLIO --
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT RATE IMPACT
NOW WE CAN SAY IN THE BILL THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THIS
DOESN'T HAVE AN UNREASONABLE.
IMPACT ON RATES WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT DO YOU
CONSIDER AND REASONABLE WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED OUR PS.
THERE WAS A WARNING FROM THE
CPUC THAT THIS COULD RAISE RATES
FOR RESIDENTIAL CONSUMERS
UPWARDS OF 30%.
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE GOT THE STATS BACK.
AND AND RESIDENTIAL ELECTRIC
ELECTRICITY RATES IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHERE 34% HIGHER.
COMMERCIAL RATES WERE 48%
HIGHER.
AN INDUSTRIAL RATES WERE 76%
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA IT NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO YOU KNOW NOW WE'VE
JUST SAID THE POLICY LAST YEAR
TO GO.
TO FIFTY NOW WE'RE GONNA SET UP
PLANNING GOAL THE SIXTY TO A
HUNDRED WHERE THE RATES GOING TO
GO THAT THE WE KNOW HISTORY IS
THE BEST INDICATOR OF WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN RATES ARE GOING
TO INCREASE.
WHO'S GOING TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
AN UNREASONABLE IMPACTOR RATES
IS IT GONNA BE THE LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO BE AN AGENCY.
WHO'S GOING TO DETERMINE WHAT'S
DOMENICI'S.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
DEFINE.
AND THE PROBLEM IS.
HERE'S A REALITY AND MANHATTAN
MANHATTAN INSTITUTE DID A STUDY
ON THIS.
AND THEY SAID THAT NEARLY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
LIVE IN ENERGY POVERTY WHICH
MEANS THEY PAY MORE THAN 10%.
OTHER DISPOSABLE INCOME FOR
ELECTRICITY.
THAT'S A VERY TOUGH THING TO
SWALLOW ESPECIALLY IN MY
DISTRICT.
I THINK IN YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL
SENATOR I AND IN MANY PARTS OF
IN THE CALIFORNIA THEY POINT OUT
THAT.
YOU KNOW SAN FRANCISCO IT'S ONLY
THREE POINT 6% LIVE ENERGY
POLICY.
BUT IN EMLYN CENTRAL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA'S 15%.
THAT LIVE IN THAT.
AT THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THINGS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT DIRECT
AXIS THAT IS AND THAT.
THAT'S LIKE SWATTING AND THAT
THE BIG COST DRIVER.
IN CALIFORNIA AND ENERGY HAS
BEEN OUR PS PERIOD IS RAISE
RATES TO CERTAIN WOULDN'T LOSE
CHAIR.
UP LET ME JUST FINISH NOW AND
YOU AYE YOU CAN RESPOND TO EACH
OF THESE THINGS BUT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS IT HAS RAISE
RATES.
AND IS MADE IT VERY HARD WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST.
ENERGY IS PART OF THAT BECAUSE
IT'S PART OF OUR DISPOSE IF YOU
CAN'T GET AROUND YOUR P. JEANNIE
BILL BELIEVE ME I'M A FATHER.
AND MY WIFE THE MOTHER WE PAY
THE BILL.
EVERY DOLLARYEAH AYE AYES AYE
CUT YOU OFF BUT I THINK AND IN
ORDER -- FOR
THE SENATOR TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION THEN
MAYBE YOU CAN JUST.
I WILL I WILL BE I WILL BE VERY
FAMILIAR AT ALL WITH THE COURT
HELD A NEWS OF THE FINISH UP THE
LAST COUPLE POINTS AND THEN I
WOULD I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
SENATOR RESPOND TO THIS BECAUSE
AT THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT --
ONE WE CAN'T SUSTAIN BASELOAD
POWER THAT'S THE ISSUE YOU CAN'T
SUSTAIN BASE LOW POWER ON
RENEWABLE.
RESOURCES ALONE ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO COUNT HYDRO
AND THAT'S STILL AN OPEN
QUESTION --
ENERGY DEMAND IS GOING TO
INCREASE NOT GO DOWN BECAUSE
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
ALL THESE CHARGING STATIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
GUESS WHAT NEED ELECTRICITY.
TO PROVIDE THESE CHARGING
STATIONS INTO CHARGE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
SO IT'S GONNA GO UP AND IF IF IF
POWERS INTERMITTENT.
AND FROM WHAT WILL MOSTLY A
SOLARIUM WHEN.
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT BASE OF
POWER WE'RE GOING TO NEED
NATURAL GAS WE'RE GOING TO NEED
HYDRO.
THOSE THINGS TO HELP
[inaudible]
SUSTAIN IT.
JOBS VERY QUICKLY --
YES THIS HAS CREATED SOME.
VERY GOOD PAYING CONSTRUCTION
JOBS ON THE FRONT END.
BUT THE LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
JOBS LIKE THOSE IN THE NATURAL
GAS PLANT THIS IN MY DISTRICT
CALPINE THAT WAS SHATTERED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND NOW IS BACK
OPEN BECAUSE WE KNOW WE NEED IT.
WE SHATTERED IT.
LET EVERYBODY OFF NOW WE BROUGHT
RIGHT BACK ON BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THEY NEED THE POWER THOSE ARE
GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT SUSTAIN
PEOPLE LONG TERM.
NOT JUST FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
PERIOD BUT HEY PEOPLE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THERE AND
MAINTAIN THEIR SO THERE IS A BIG
IMPACT TO JOBS FROM THAT.
STANDPOINT AND WE NEED LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE JOBS AS WELL.
FIRES WE'VE ALWAYS HAD FIRES AND
AS SOMEONE WHO'S FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRUSTS ME WE'VE BEEN
SAYING FOR THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS.
SO THEY DON'T NEED AYE AYE AGAIN
I I DON'T WANT TO BE --
RUDE BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE WRAP UP YOUR VERY
INTERESTING AND VERY APPROPRIATE
--
STATEMENT [inaudible]
WITH.
CLEAR QUESTION SO THAT WE CAN
POSE IT TO THE IT OF THE AUTHOR
--
AND THEN WE CAN LOOK TO SEE IF
ANYONE ELSE HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
AND THEN MOVE ON WITH THAT THE
HEARING SO I PREACH I KNOW THIS
IS MORE OF A STATEMENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN RELATED IS IT'S PART OF
THAT THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THEIR VERY IMPORTANT POINTS THAT
WE SHOULD ALL CONSIDER WHEN
WE'RE GOING TO PASS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT
[inaudible]
THIS IT'S OKAY TO TAKE TIME AND
COMMITTEE ADDED I KEEP SAYING
THAT IT'S OKAY TO TAKE TIME
COMMITTEE THESE ARE IMPORTANT
THINGS RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA PASS SIGNIFICANT
POLICY THAT AFFECTS THE ENTIRE
STATE.
AND I WILL MY DAD IF I COULD AND
I WILL SOME A LITTLE VERY THIS
HAS BEEN BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE NEW TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
ABILITY YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WANT
TO PUT YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
RECORD.
BUT YOU'VE HAD --
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME TO
DO SO SO IF YOU COULD JUST WRAP
UP AND THEN WE CAN.
MOVE FORWARD WITH RESPOND LET ME
JUST M. WITH FIRES.
FIRE IS NOT A NEW NORMAL IS NOT
A NEW NORMAL WE HAVE HAD FIRED
SIGNIFICANT FOREST FIRES AND FOR
THE PAST AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SAYING WE NEED
BETTER FORESTRY MANAGEMENT WE
NEED TO CLEAN CLEAN HAVE BETTER
MANAGEMENT IN OUR FORCE.
IN ORDER TO HAVE A MORE
SUSTAINABLE FORCE AND NOT HAVE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES THAT WE FED.
THAT'S IN THE NORTH STATE THAT'S
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO.
AND WE'VE HAD THESE FIRES CAN WE
HAVE THEM EVERY YEAR WE'VE HAD
THEM EVERY YEAR NOW I WILL ADMIT
THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS EXACERBATED
THAT BUT WE'VE ALWAYS HAD IT.
AND THE PROBLEM IS WE'VE DONE.
ESSENTIALLY ZERO ON FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT AND THAT'S THE
BIGGEST CARBON EMITTER IN THE
STATE.
THE BIGGEST CARBON EMITTER IN
THE STATE IS FOR SOME WE DONE
VIRTUALLY NOTHING ABOUT IT.
SO THAT'S GREAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
OR ELECTRICAL GRID.
ZERO BUT YOU STILL HAVE ALL
THESE FOUR SPIRES OF THE DON'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CARBON EMISSION
AND IF WE BUY POWER FROM OTHER
WESTERN STATES WERE DOING COAL
FIRED PLANTS.
WHO ARE DOING HYDRO THAT WE
WON'T DO --
YEAH I MEAN DOES THAT MAKE ANY
KIND OF SENSE WHILE OUR RATE
PAYERS PAY EXPONENTIALLY MORE.
AND LIVE IN ENERGY POVERTY.
THAT TO ME IS JUST NOT A LONG
TERM --
VIABLE PLAN FOR ENERGY AYE I
THINK THERE'S A LOT WE TALK
ABOUT THIS LOT THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT WE NEED TO GET IT RIGHT.
AND THAT MEANS TAKING A PAUSE
AND MAYBE NOT JUST FAST
FORWARDING ON THIS ONE WE JUST
DID A MANDATE LAST YEAR --
AND WITHOUT ALL AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU IF I IF I
COULD TURN DOCTOR QUIRK AND THEN
AND SO THERE ARE. TWO THINGS
FIRST OF ALL --
COMMENT ON DO YOU S. TAX RULES
TO MEN IN THIS IS SET TO FIND
HIS POINT 25% SUCH A PRETTY LOW
NUMBER -- SO
I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
YEAH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION TO
PASS ON TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR --
IT'S FRIEDMAN YOU HAD A GOOD
QUESTION AND THEN MR GARCIA I
JUST HAVE A QUICK COMMENT THAT'S
OKAY VERY --
FIRST -- YOU
JUST TO TAKE AYE I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE COMMENTS THE DETAILS
--
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE TECHNICAL.
PART OF THE BILL AND THIS IS A
GOAL AND GOING FORWARD THERE
WILL BE OTHER LEGISLATION I'M
SURE THAT WILL IMPACT THIS.
AND IF THERE AREDEFICIENCIES
OTHER LEGISLATION COULD ALWAYS
BE INTRODUCED. TO TAKE ON ANY OF
THOSE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT CERTAIN TYPES OF VERNE OF
HYDROGEN CAN BE RENEWABLE OTHER
LEGISLATION COULD ALWAYS BE
INTRODUCED. TO DEAL WITH THOSE
SUBJECTS IN ANYTHING AT THIS
BILL --
HASN'T TACKLE BUT JUST AT THE
HIGH LEVEL ALL OF THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THIS BILL PALE IN
COMPARISON WITH THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PRICE OF RENEWABLE SOMETIMES
BEING HIGHER ON THAT WILL AS WE
SAW WITH SOLAR AS THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE INTRODUCED THAT
BRINGS THE PRICE DOWN AND HIS
NEW TRANSMISSION IS INTRODUCED
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE IN SOME
PLACES.
THAT BRINGS THE PRICE DOWN
BRINGS THE TREATMENT DEALS OF
THE TRANSMISSION PROBLEM BUT YOU
NEVER HAVE THE DRIVER TO BRING
THOSE NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO MARKET
OR TO DEAL WITH TRANSMISSION
ISSUES IN AREAS THAT ARE HAVING
TRANSMISSION ISSUES.
WITHOUT HAVING A STRONG MARKET
SIGNAL SUCH AS IS BEING OB
CREATED BY THIS BILL.
AND THAT'S WHY HAVING THESE
GOALS IS SO IMPORTANT TO SHOW
INVESTORS THAT THERE IS --
ARE NEAT THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR THE TECHNOLOGIES OF THEY DO
INVEST THEIR DOLLARS --
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IS THERE --
NEEDING TO PURCHASE THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND THAT'S WHY EVEN
THOUGH WE MAY BE A SMALL PART OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMITTER IS
FOR THE ENTIRE PLANET WHAT WE DO
HERE IS SO IMPORTANT.
AYE LAST YEAR I WAS VERY HONORED
TO HAVE BEEN SENT --
TO GERMANY TO BE PART OF THE
COPE CONFERENCE WHICH IS THE
PARIS ACCORD GROUP.
AND THE NUMBER OF COUNTRIES THAT
WALKED UP TO THE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION AND SAID WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH CAP AND TRADE IN WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE IN CALIFORNIA IS
SO IMPORTANTTO THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
AND HOW DID YOU DO IT HOW DID
YOU GET YOUR RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
TO THIS LEVEL WE DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU WERE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
SO WHAT WE DO TO SET THAT --
TO BE THE LEADER FOR THE WORLD
I'M IS BEING WATCHED AND BILLS
LIKE THIS ARE VERY IMPORTANT --
BEYOND WHAT THEY MIGHT DO FOR
GRIT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
JUST IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M WORK CALIFORNIA GOES IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY THE WORLD
WILL GO.
AND THE ACTION THAT WE'RE TAKING
TODAY IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE IS NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
TO ANY OF US AND TO OUR CHILDREN
THAN TO HAVE A HABITABLE PLANET.
AND THAT IS IN QUESTION RIGHT
NOW.
UNDENIABLY AND SO YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T MESS AROUND ANY LONGER AND
WE HAVE TO TAKE STRONG STEPS SO
I'M REALLY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
SUB TODAY.
ON THIS COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
CAST THIS VOTE I WANNA THANK THE
CHAIR AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BRUCE CHAIRED.
SENATOR FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
AND GO FOR BEING A LEADER --
FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THE ISSUES OF THE CLIMATE
AND OUR ECONOMIC GUN GOALS THAT
INTERSECT.
I'M AN ASSOCIATE MYSELF UP TO
ABOUT. 30% OF WHAT MISTER
GALLAGHER HAS SAID AND I THINK
THAT'S A CONSERVATIVE NUMBER --
I MIGHT BE HIGH BUT NEVER THE
LESS YOU HE MADE SOME POINTS
THAT I'D LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH AS IT RELATES.
TO QUESTION THAT HE POSES AS A
RELEASE ZERO CARBON ENERGY.
I THINK REALLY THE QUESTION IS
THAT THE A DIRECT THAT TO TO
STEAL A WORD FROM YOU WOULD HAVE
DONE THIS QUITE OFTEN.
THE INTENTIONALITY RIGHT WHAT
WHAT EXACTLY ARE WE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THERE AND YOU KNOW I
THINK HE WENT TO BAT.
FOR YOU KNOW MY CONSTITUENTS AS
IT RELATES TO THE GEOTHERMAL.
AND THE NEED TO DIVERSIFY THE
PURPLE YOU RIGHT NOW I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
PORTFOLIO IS NOT DIVERSE THAT
THE LOW COST BEST.
FIT MODEL HAS NOT WORKED. TO
MEETING THOSE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES.
AYE ON THE WAY OVER HERE AND A
CONVERSATION IN PASSING WITH
SOMEONE ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT.
ALL RENEWABLES THAT MAKES SENSE
FROM OUR ECONOMIC STANDPOINT
FROM A TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT.
DO NOT GET LEFT BEHIND AND
CERTAINLY NOT TRYING TO STEAL.
A LINE THERE FROM AND SOME
PERSON THAT THAT SERVED.
IN DC AT SOME POINT BUT WE
REALLY THINK.
THAT THERE IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO LOOKING AT ALL
OF THE RENEWABLES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE PARTICULARLY --
AS WE ARE PRESSED WITH THESE
FIRES THAT IT THERE'S A QUESTION
AT HAND ON HOW DO WE UTILIZE A
BIOMASS --
TECHNOLOGIES ARE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE THAT TREATS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GIVEN THAT --
THAT IS BEFORE US TODAY HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THESE ECONOMICALLY
DISTRESSED.
PARTS OF THE STATE.
THAT NEED THOSE JOBS AND IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CALPINE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE IMPERIAL
COUNTY REGION THAT HAS 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT AT TIMES.
HOW WE HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE RENEWABLES ARE INTEGRATED
AS WELL AND THAT THE COST?
ISN'T SOLELY THE ONLY
MEASUREMENT.
OF BEING ABLE TO INTEGRATE THESE
RENEWABLES AREN'T INTO THE
PORTFOLIO STANDARDS WE HAVE.
US SOME WORK TO DO AND CLEARLY
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT A COUPLE
TIMES OF THIS IS IN THE AND ALL
BOMB NO HEARING WE'RE GOING TO
SEE.
SOME WORK HAPPENING DURING THE
SUMMER BREAK IN --
I I'D BE REMISS IF I DID IN HIGH
[inaudible]
WHETHER POLICY PROPOSALS THAT
ARE MOVING BEFORE THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AT THIS COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE SENATE HAS SEEN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT
REGIONALIZATION --
THE CONVERSATION --
ABOUT --
GOOD GRADE RELIABILITY
DISCUSSIONS OUR PROCUREMENT --
SOME WILL CALL --
ARE BILL THAT A CARVE OUT --
CALL IT WHAT YOU WILL WHAT WE'RE
INTENDING ON DOING IS WE'RE
TRYING TO DIVERSIFY THE
PORTFOLIO.
AND LOOKING AT IT FROM DIFFERENT
LENSES I THINK IS CRITICAL A
SOLAR IS IMPORTANT TO US IN THE
STATE WIND.
IS MUTUALLY IMPORTANT --
TO OUR REGION AND UP BUT THERE
ARE OTHER RENEWABLE --
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE
TO MEET.
THIS GOAL THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE OF A 100%.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IT'S NOT A
QUESTION IT'S MORE OF A THE
COMMENT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN WE GET THERE.
THAT THAT WE'RE PUTTING ALL THIS
INTO PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THIS WORKS UNLESS WE HAVE
A ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
REGIONALIZATION I DON'T THINK IT
WORKS.
ON AS WE TALK ABOUT DIVERSIFYING
THE PORTFOLIO CERTAINLY DON'T
THINK IT WORKS FOR ME.
IF WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU
ARE MORE IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION SPIC YOU MUCH --
SERVICE IN THE OBVIOUSLY THROUGH
CHARITIES WANNA RECOGNIZE YOUR
INCREDIBLE YOU KNOW LEADERSHIP
ON A JEW THURMOND I THINK YOU'RE
THE KING OF GEOTHERMAL.
YOU KNOW OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU'RE
IT'S VERY PROUD AS WILL'S
GEOTHERMAL VERY PROUD IN IN YOUR
A REGION THAT YOU REPRESENT YOU
BEEN A CHAMPION YOU FIGHT HARD
YOU KNOW --
NOT JUST YOU KNOW REPUBLICANS
BUT DEMOCRATS ALIKE --
TO TO PROTECTING. TO TO GROW
YOUR INTERESTS AND AND AND
YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK THAT WHEN
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU DIVERSIFY.
A PORTFOLIO --
AND HAVE EVERY TOOL BOX A
INITIATIVE THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE THE LOWEST AND AND BEST
A COST.
OF TO THE CONSUMER A THE BETTER
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT --
SO I JUST WANNA --
THINK YOU'RE MUCH MORE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND AND AND YOU'RE
CHAMPIONING.
BOB WE WILL TURN TO A VICE
CHAIRMAN'S PATTERSON THEN DOCTOR
EGGMAN THAN MISTER MERCER AT
TIMES CHAIRMAN APPRECIATED DOT
JUST COMMENT --
AND WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE SEEN THE
BILL -- DOES.
STANDING DISCUSSIONS.
AND WITH RESPECT TO IT ARM I
JUST WANNA RESPECTFULLY REMIND
ALL OF US --
THAT THE OPPOSITION RAISES SOME
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS.
AND AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THIS
OMMITTEE FOR CONSUMER PERIOD OF
TIME I HAVE SEEN THE
CONSEQUENCES.
UP WE HAVE VERY RAPID A RAMP UP
--
WE HAVE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS A OF DEMAND TWINS WIND
AND SOLAR IS GOING AWAY --
THE RESULT OF THAT HAS BEEN THAT
THERE THAT THE GRID HAS BEEN --
MADE RELIABLE AND BALANCED BY
LARGE HYDRO.
BY NATURAL GAS AND BY IMPORTS
ALL OF WHICH ARE IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER.
SUSPECT BY AN UP AND MANY PEOPLE
IN THIS --
NOW IN IN THIS LEGISLATURE WE
ARE DOING THE SAME THING OVER
AGAIN THAT WE DON BEFORE.
THIS WILL INCREASE RATES.
THIS WILL DECREASE RELIABILITY.
THAT COST ANALYSIS HERE I THINK
IS M. DE OF ART IS AMBIGUOUS IT
IS THE SAME KIND OF AMBIGUITY
THAT I THINK --
RAISES SOME SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT THEIR WHAT KIND OF RATE
INCREASES ARE WE GOING TO SEE.
I REALLY DO THINK THAT --
THE LACK OF SPECIFICITY WITH
RESPECT OFF RAMPS ARE.
A MAJOR CONCERN FOR ME.
AND I JUST WANNA ECHO THE
OPPONENTS CONCERNS OF WHY I'M
GOING TO VOTE NO [inaudible]
NOT NOW THIS IS A LEAP OF FAITH
AND A GAMBLE GIVEN THE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES OUR RATEPAYERS.
AND OUR EMPLOYERS ARE IN AT
PRESENTLY AS A RESULT THE
PREVIOUS POLICY SO I'M GONNA
RESPECTFULLY BUT NO [inaudible]
PATRICK.
I GUESS WE'LL JUST HAVE MAKING
STATEMENTS NOW --
GA AND I WILL I WILL BE BRIEF
SINCE AYE I WOULD ASSOCIATE SOME
AYE COMES WITH MR GALLAGHER AND
MR GARCIA BUT JUST ON THIS ISSUE
OF AND I MEAN TO TO MISTREATMENT
--
TO YOU TO GO BACK.
TO USING MY FORMER CAREER AS A
AS A THERAPIST OFTENTIMES WHEN
WE LOOK WITH WHICH THEY WERE
WITH THE NBA THE WORLD WHEN WE
LOOK AT SOMEBODY ELSE'S FAMILY
DOWN THE STREET THEY LOOK LIKE
THEY'VE GOT IT ALL TOGETHER. TO
GET INSIDE THE HOUSE RIGHT AND
THEN YOU SEE THAT THIS THERE'S
MORE ISSUES GOING ON THEN IT
LOOKS LIKE FROM THE OUTSIDE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH HERE RIGHT WE
HOLD OURSELVES OUT AS A BEACON
TO THE WORLD AND YET WHEN YOU
GET DOWN INTO A WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIVISION IN THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS THAT WE STILL NEED TO
WORK OUT.
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT SIGNALS TO
THE MARKET WE HAVE SIGNAL TO THE
MARKET BEFORE AND HAVE SEEN
INVESTMENT AND NOW WE'RE SEEING
UP DIFFERENT SIGNALS RATE AND
WE'RE WE'RE SHIFTING SIGNALS.
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
I THINK WE NEED TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL BALANCING AND ALSO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO.
THAT AGAIN WE ARE VERY INCLUSIVE
AND OF THAT I'M ALSO VERY
CONCERNED OF THE FLUORESCENT
BIOMASS AND AND HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE INCLUDE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
WHILE THEY MAY NOT BE THE MOST
CLAIM.
THEY HAVE SO MANY ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THAT OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT NEED THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE LIKE A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF THE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF OF OF RENEWABLES AND MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE ARE COMPREHENSIVE IN HOW
WE LOOK AT THAT SO THAT MEANS.
I'M ALSO TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY AB BUT CAUTION AS WE
GO FORWARD AND MULTIPLE.
IN THIS FRIEDMAN HAD A BILL
EARLIER ON ELECTRIFICATION UPSET
GLAD YOU TOOK NOBODY'S COMING
WITH THESE GREAT IDEAS.
BUT AGAIN AS WE TALK ABOUT
SIGNALS TO THE MARKET.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHAT WHAT IS
AND WHAT IS NOT.
AND HOW DO WE LOOK AT ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THAT OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
[inaudible]
USE [inaudible]
RESEARCHING.
THANK YOU SENATOR I AM A 100% IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR 100%.
CLEAN ENERGY ACT.
AT THE SAME TIME I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE VICE CHAIR AND BY
MISTER GALLAGHER.
I SHARE ALL THOSE COSTS THE
IMPACT [inaudible]
OF HIGHER.
COST SON RATEPAYERS THE
FRAGMENTED MARKET.
THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES AND HOW
WE ARE TRYING TO SORT THROUGH.
ALL OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
WILD FIRES ARE ARE POSING UPON
[inaudible]
OUR STATE.
IN OF COURSE THE ONGOING
CHALLENGES OF INSURING.
A LOT ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE MY LAST
COMMENT --
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION INDICATED THAT THIS
IS A LOT OF A GOAL BUT NOT NOW.
AND MY RESPONSE IS IF NOT NOW
WHEN.
YOU NO SCIENTISTS AROUND THE
WORLD.
MANY ARE SAYING THAT WE HAVE.
PERHAPS ALREADY SURPASSED THE
TIPPING POINT [inaudible]
FROM WHICH OUR EARTH.
CAN NOT RETURN.
AND SO I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK.
A TO MY DAUGHTER AND TO ALL OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS. TO BE OF THE
SAY.
WHAT DID I DO? TO HELP FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE GREATEST CHALLENGE.
FACING HUMANITY ON OUR PLANET
EARTH.
FULL RECOGNITION OF ALL.
THE MAN'S CHALLENGES ARRESTED AT
A CALIFORNIA'S FACING.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS.
A BOLD AND NECESSARY STEP.
SAVE OUR PLANET.
THANK YOU OF MISTER MAY.
JUST QUICKLY MISTER CHAIR HAD
JUST FOR POINT OF CLARIFICATION
BY MR QUIRK TALKED ABOUT
DIMINISHED BEING DEFINED AS
POINT TWO FIVE OR LESS.
AMUSING THE IRS AS A DEFINITION
IS THAT WHAT DOES THAT DIMINISH
MEANS IS LESS THAN POINT TWO
FIVE AND IS THAT ANNUALLY.
ALL OF THE EQUIPMENT
[inaudible]
BUT THAT.
SAID TO MINIMIZE DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE A AND THAT'S A THAT'S AN
UNKNOWN NAM TO DO IT'S UP TO OF
ITS ITS SUBJECTIVE THING. TO
MINIMIZE I DON'T THINK IT'S
OBJECTIVE BASED ON THE BASELINE
--
XANDER FROM THE US.
I'M NOT A LAWYER I'M JUST
QUOTING WHAT THE COURTS HAVE
DECIDED OUGHT IN GENERAL OF
THEIR OTHER PRECEDENTS FROM THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND IT GENERALLY
MEANS A PRETTY SMALL AMOUNT
THAT.
ORDINARILY PEOPLE WOULD NOT
NOTICE AND THAT'S BEEN REPEATED
BY VARIOUS DECISIONS.
I CAN'T SAY FOR SURE WHAT WOULD
BE RULED HERE BUT I WOULD BE
VERY SURPRISED IF SOMETHING
LIKE.
A QUARTER OF PERCENT ISN'T
WHAT'S DECIDED DIMINISH.
SUPPOSE TO MEAN SOMETHING YOU
WOULDN'T NOTICE THAT'S FROM THE
LATIN.
AND IT GOES TO A PREDATOR DOES
NOT --
CONCERN HIMSELF WITH TRIFLES.
AND THAT'S WHERE DE MINIMUS
COMES FROM THANK YOU.
I JERRY BROWN'S THAT THE ONLY
ONE WHO KNOWS LATIN.
WELL I WAS SURPRISED BY THAT
ANSWER THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK.
DOCTOR CROW THAT'LL BE HOLD
ANOTHER HEARING ACROSS THE HALL.
AS AND IT IT WILL BE DENIED THE
DOCTOR QUIRK DOCTOR QUIRK OF
COURSE COLORS --
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT IT IS TO BE
A ROCKET SCIENTIST --
SO [inaudible]
BUT AS SENATOR JUST WANTED TO
ASK THE QUESTION --
FOR SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS BOTH
SAMMY DINO COUNTY AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY --
THAT WHEN A BUILDING SOLAR LARGE
SCALE SOLAR AND WIND FACILITIES
--
I HAVE TAKEN --
FOR SOME ESPECIALLY MONTH
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY THOSE
WERE LAND CONSERVATIONISTS --
HAVE FELT THAT WE'VE TAKEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF OF BURDEN --
TO BE ABLE TO AND TO AND IN FACT
SOME WOULD ARGUE HAVE DAMAGED --
ARE ARE ARE A PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
LANDS WHAT WHEN YOU'RE MOVING ON
THE RPF STANDARD UP THAT MEANS
THERE CAN BE MORE SOLAR AND
WIND.
HAVE WE BEEN THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH --
THAT THAT THE TWO COUNTIES SOME
OF THE WORKING WITH COUNTIES ALL
OVER THE STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT
FROM A LAND USE PERSPECTIVE WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET THERE.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION A
MISTER MAYES AND THEM I HAVE NOT
I CAN'T SAY THAT I SPECIFICALLY
HAVE ENGAGE WITH COUNTY
OFFICIALS EITHER FROM SAN
BERNARDINO OR RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FOR THAT MATTER.
IN THE OTHER COUNTIES THAT --
MAYES SPECIFICALLY HOST --
LARGE --
UTILITY SCALE FOR EXAMPLE --
I'D BE MORE HAPPY THAT TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU I I KNOW THAT SOME OF
INTERNAL.
CONFLICTS IF YOU WILL PERHAPS IN
THE MOJAVE DESERT TO IN IN YOUR
BACKYARD WITH REGARDS --
TO AMOEBA MENTAL'S --
SPACE AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OF THE UTILI SKILL SOLAR
RAYS HAVE HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT.
CONTROVERSIAL THE AYE AYE EGG
KNOWLEDGE IT YOU KNOW I
RECOGNIZE IT --
THAT WOULD SAY AM I I'M MORE
HAPPY THAT THAT OTHER SPEC TO
YOU AND YOU KNOW IT'S A FORMER
LEADER OF OF THE REPUBLICANS
ASSEMBLY MORE HAPPY TO GET WITH
YOU ON MY STAFF TING ENGAGE WITH
YOUR STAFF. TO TO ENGAGE IN SOME
THE SENSITIVITY I'M GOING TO
WHAT MS FRIEDMAN SAID --
THIS SUSAN GOODNESS SUMMER
SAATCHI THIS IS A A A AN
EXISTENTIALIST RIGHT NOT TO OUR
SURVIVABILITY PARA AS AN ECONOMY
NAM AS A AS A COMMUNITY WHAT THE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT ALIKE
COME.
ON BUT THEN THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE
STRONGLY WE HAVE TO TO TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT TO YOUR POINT --
THAT MORE NAPA TO ENGAGE WITH
THE OFFLINE STUFF TO STAFF FOR
PRINCIPLE THE PRINCIPLE OF A
LEAD THEN TURNED UP TO YOU
[inaudible]
WHICH RISK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AYE BY.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING SOME OF THAT
THE DISCUSSION AND ALSO WHEN YOU
PRESENTED TO NATURAL RESOURCES
AS WELL --
MOVES ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THAT
DISCUSSION AS WELL.
I I DO ONE ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE MS FRIEDMAN --
I ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING WITH YOU ALSO AND WITH
MISS FRIEDMAN IN GERMANY.
THE UNITED NATIONS ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE ARE THE LEADERS AND THEY DO
LOOK TO US TO SEE WHAT IT IS WE
ARE GOING TO DO --
WITHOUT A DOUBT WE HAVE TO FIND
THAT BALANCE BETWEEN RELIABILITY
AND OF THE THE COST --
BUT WE KNOW WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
BUT UNLESS WE ARE WILLING TO BE
AS MR MOZER CHIU SAID TO BE.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND I WANT TO ADD TO WHAT MISTER
MARTUCCI SAID.
HE SAID IF NOT NOW THEN WHEN.
IF NOT US THEN WHO.
WE ARE THE LEADERS THEY ARE
LOOKING TO US SO I DO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
STUFF THANK YOU MUCH
[inaudible]
HER [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO I DON'T GET INVITED TO ANY OF
THOSE THINGS SO AND THIS IS
PROBABLY WHY BECAUSE OF THE
THING AND GARY TO SAY NOW.
IS THE AND I'LL AYE MY COMMENTS
WITH GALLAGHER AND AND MR GARCIA
I I THINK IF WE CARE ABOUT
RENEWABLES WE SHOULD TREAT THEM
ALL SPECIAL.
AND I THINK THAT THOUGH THERE
ARE ISSUES WITH BIOMASS AND
GEOTHERMAL THAT WE HAVEN'T
ADDRESSED AND THEY THINK THAT
WHEN WE SAY WE GIVE A SIGNAL TO
THE MARKET YES LEGISLATION GIVES
A SIGNAL TO THE MARKET.
BUT YES LEGISLATION GIVES A
SIGNAL TO THE MARKET BUT WE ALSO
SUBSIDIZING THAT GIVES A SIGNAL
TO THE MARKET.
TOO SOON WE SUBSIDIZE SOLAR WE
DON'T TAKE CARE OF BIOMASS AND
SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES I DON'T
WORK A LOT IN ENVIRONMENT I WORK
A LOT AND ENERGY AND EIGHT
DEATHLY WORKING POVERTY.
AND I KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE SUFFERED
TREMENDOUSLY FROM PLACES LIKE
CALPINE CLOSING.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A COMMUNITY THIS
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE NOT TAKEN
CARE OF AND THERE IS ENERGY
POVERTY AND I COME FROM A
COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE THEY CAN
HAVE SIX HOLES IN THE SIX HOLES
IN THEIR SELLING FOR LIGHTS AND
THEY PUT TO WIN BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THEIR ELECTRICITY.
SO.
I REALIZE WE STATES TO MINIMIZE
BUT I THINK IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE MINDFUL OF
ALL COMMUNITIES WHETHER I MEAN I
HAVE FOR TREASON MY COMMUNITY
LET'S BE HONEST BIOMASS SHOULD
NOT BE ONE OF MY MAJOR ISSUES.
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE ALL COMMUNITIES WE
REPRESENT WE WE WE LEGISLATE
WITH HOME IN MIND BUT WE DO
RIGHT REPRESENT THE WHOLE STATE
AND I DO THINK.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN --
UNFAIR TO SOME RENEWABLES AND I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD THAT YOU TREAT ALL WHEN
YOU LOOK AT YOUR LEGISLATION
THAT YOU TREAT OLIVER NOBLE SO
SPECIAL.
AND REALIZE THAT THAT'S THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE LEGISLATION
BUT IT IS HOW WE TRULY TREAT
EFFORT RENEWABLE.
OR ANY OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO TO COMMENT HEARING ON SENATOR
I THINK THAT.
IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN CLEAR THAT
YOU'VE CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY.
OF FOR THIS LEGISLATURE BUT NOT
JUST LEGISLATURE THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEYOND. TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS IT MEAN TO
GET TO A 100% WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE.
WELL HOW DO WE DESIGN A PATHWAYS
TO GET THERE AND UNDERSCORING
MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SAID THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH.
A THREAT TO THE WAY THAT WE LIVE
THAT WAY THEY ARE GO EVEN OUR
EXISTENCE.
AND SO TO THAT UNDERSTANDING OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT'S THAT
WHO WHAT IT'S DOING.
A TO THE PLANET.
WHAT ARE THE KINDS OF
INITIATIVES THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
UNDERTAKE?
AB THIRTY TWO S. B..
THIRTY TWO YOUR S. B. THREE
FIFTY THESE ARE ALL PART OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEEDED TO
HAPPEN WE'RE TIMELY AND LATE IN
PLACE --
MARKERS THAT SORT OF GAVE US AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY.
OF MOVE INTO THE FUTURE AND SO
START TO ESTABLISH OF STRATEGIES
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSED THE LARGER
ISSUE AT HAND.
AND IN SO DOING.
AND IN SO DOING WE BECAME
RECOGNIZED AS A WORLD LEADER.
THOSE ARE TOUGH DECISIONS WHEN
THOSE BILLS WERE PASSED.
THE SAME TYPE OF OPPOSITION WAS
AT THE TABLE BASICALLY SAYING
THAT THESE ARE GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT GOALS TO ATTAIN.
TO BUT WE WERE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WE ARE STILL MOVING FORWARD
AS WAS POINTED OUT BY ONE OF THE
TESTIMONIES THAT DESCRIBED.
WORK IN PROGRESS UNDER THREE
FIFTY AND NOW WE'RE SETTING A
NEW MARKER.
BUT I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
I THINK IT IS ALSO UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE ARE NOT STOPPING.
WITH SP ONE HUNDRED AND ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE ADDRESSED
IN TERMS OF POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES.
I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE OR REAL
--
FIRE LIABILITY IT'S REAL --
DEPARTING CUSTOMERS IT'S REAL SO
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES ARE
REALLY DEALING WITH SOME SERIOUS
ISSUES AND I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT.
HOW WE ADDRESS HYDRO THE VICE
CHAIR HAD A BILL EARLIER THIS
YEAR THAT THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED --
IN THE CATEGORY OF RENEWABLES WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE AREAS
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE. TO TO
EXPLORE AND I THINK AND WHAT YOU
HAVE SAID AND WHAT I HEARD THE
EARLIER TESTIMONY AND COMMENTS
FROM DOCTOR THE DOCTORS EGGMAN
--
AND QUIRK --
IT DAVID MAKER COMMITTEE VERY
SMART WE APPRECIATE THEIR
PARTICIPATION BUT I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THERE ARE STILL.
OPPORTUNITY IN THE FUTURE TO
START TO BE TO REAL REALLY DRILL
DOWN.
ON MANY OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE BEING RAISED TODAY
RIGHTFULLY SO [inaudible]
LAST WEEK.
WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF DIRECT
ACCESS.
AND RAISING THE CAP ON THAT
BECAUSE WE GOT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF CHOICE
BUT IN SO DOING WE MAY HAVE PUT
OURSELVES IN A INTERESTING PLACE
OF WHETHER NOT THAT WOULD CAUSE
AN INCREASE TO RATES.
SO WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEFORE US AND WE KNOW THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING.
A COMPREHENSIVE GOOD JOB.
OF BEING MINDFUL TO THE END GOAL
AND THAT IS REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
THAT ARE LEADING.
TO THE CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEFORE US.
AND SO IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE
ABLE TO TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY -- I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION [inaudible]
CONTINUING --
WHATEVER NEW JOB YOU HAVE DOWN
THE ROAD YOU'LL COME BACK AND
CONTINUE.
TO LINEAR INSIGHT TO WHAT WILL
BE DEALING WITH IN THE FUTURE
WHICH IT DOESN'T STOP.
WITH THIS ACTION TODAY IT
CONTINUES AND TO MISTER GARTH.
GARCIA IS POINTED ALSO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HE WAS
ADDRESSING AND ON MISTER
GALLAGHER'S COMMENTS --
WE RECOGNIZE THE CAPACITY OF
BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS --
CENTRAL PROCUREMENT.
AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE A A
STRATEGY OF HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD IS GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD AS
WELL.
AND SO WE EVER THANK YOU.
FOR NOT BEING PART OF THIS
[inaudible]
LARGER DISCUSSION OVER THE YEARS
--
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS WILL BE
THE LAST TIME YOU'LL MAKE YOUR
WAY TO THIS COMMITTEE WAS
LEGISLATION --
DURING YOUR TENURE AS A SENATOR
AS A LEGISLATOR.
A SO LET ME JUST SAY THANK YOU.
OF FOR ALL YOUR BOLD.
POSITIONS AND YOUR BOLD
STATEMENT AND YOU'RE WILLING TO
STEP OUT IN FRONT AND AND DEAL
WITH THE TOUGH ISSUES AND COME
UNDER SOME CRITICISM AND COME
UNDER SOME REAL.
QUESTIONS THAT REQUIRE ALL OF US
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER.
AND I THINK THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED VERY CLEARLY.
WHAT THIS IS DESIGNED TO DO?
AND WHAT IT STILL CREATES
OPPORTUNITY FOR US COLLECTIVELY
TO ENGAGE ON AS WE GO FORWARD.
TO MEET THAT.
VERY IMPORTANT GOAL OF GETTING
TO A 100% RENEWABLE.
SO WITH THAT --
YOU THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR YOUR
CLOTHES.
THERE'S A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
HAS BEEN SECONDED --
TO PASSED THE MEASURE --
TO THE FLOOR ME MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR YOUR YOUR KIND --
YEAR --
PERSON DEEP FELT AND AND
ELOQUENT WORDS --
YOU ALWAYS BEEN A A TRUE
GENTLEMAN AND AND AND AND A
WONDERFUL LEADER REPRESENT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN PASADENA NOW IS
THE CHAIR.
OF OF UTILITIES --
HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
I'M I WANTED MY COLLEAGUES HERE
OF A BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
LET ME UNDERSCORE A POINT I MADE
EARLIER.
I'LL BE GONE.
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
THAT BEING SAID --
ILL BE UP.
TO THOSE MEMBERS WHO SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE FEW OTHER
MEMBERS WHO DON'T SEEM IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE BEEN SORT OF
SELF IDENTIFIED AND IDENTIFIED
BY THE PUBLIC AT LARGE IS IS
LEADERS IN THIS SPACE.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO SP.
ONE HUNDRED IN THE LARGER
CONTEXT IS ACTUALLY.
SMALL WITH IN REGARDS TO LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS THAT THE COMING
[inaudible] TO PLACE.
ULTIMATE CAN BE UP TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AFTER I'M GONE.
THAT AGAIN OF SET THE MARK AND
AND AND AND CONTINUE TO TROLL
BELIEVES AS LEADERS [inaudible]
I AM GOING BACK TO THE POINT TO
UNPACK IF YOU WILL ONE OF THE
POINTS MADE BY.
THE REPRESENT OF REPRESENTING A
P. JEANNIE --
THE ISSUE WITH REGARDS.
TO OF THE THREE IOUS OVERSEEING
THE GREAT AS WELL AS TWENTY NINE
MILLION INDIVIDUAL DRIVERS WILL
TELL PIPE EMITTERS THAT.
WE HAVE.
TO WORK ON STILL WOULD WE DON'T
ABANDONED IT BUT WE DON'T TIE
THEM TOGETHER AND SAY WHAT YOU
GONNA.
SET THE STANDARD FOR US WE WANT
TO SET THE STANDARD FOR TWENTY
NINE MILLION ULTIMATES CAN BE UP
TO THIS LEGISLATURE HOW THEY
MOVE FORWARD AND HOW THE PROCEED
AND ATTACKING.
TELL PIPING MATTERS --
WITHOUT A DOUBT BILL TO BE UP TO
YOU THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
AND I'M ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR
WHEREVER I MET YOU KNOW PAST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOPE WILL BE IN
WASHINGTON YOU KNOW BUT WITH
THEM IN WASHINGTON OR THE
GOVERNMENT WASHINGTON WHY LIVE.
YOU KNOW.
A LOS ANGELES CENA WHEREABOUTS
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA LOOK FOR TO
TWO WATCHING --
ALL OF YOU MOVE FORWARD AND MOVE
MOVE THE BALL THAT WOULDN'T LET
ME SORT OF ALSO TRIED IMPACT A
COUPLE OF WHAT ISMS YOU KNOW --
THAT SORT OF PREDOMINATED --
ONE SIDE OF THE AISLE OR THE
SORT OF THE DOOMSDAY FICTION.
THE OBJECTIVE WITH REGARDS TO
MOVING FORWARD A RENEWABLE
ENERGY IS TO REDUCE RATES NOT TO
INCREASE RATES AYE BUT THERE'S
BEEN LITTLE.
OR PERHAPS A LOT OF CONFLATION
IF YOU WILL.
AS FOR THE REASONS WHY
SPECIFICALLY SOME RATES HAVE
ACTUALLY INCREASED AND SOMETIMES
WHEN WE MIGHT THE MODEL IT UP
TOGETHER AND AND DO WHAT --
KINDA LIKE A WHAT I CALL FLOOD
IN THE MORE HAPPY DID TAKE IF
YOU LIKE.
WE CERTAINLY CREATE FEAR.
THEN YOU CAN CREATE DOUBTS.
YOU KNOW YOU FUND IT UP.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHAT'S UP WHAT'S WRONG YOU KNOW
WHAT'S BLACK WHAT'S WHITE.
WHAT'S UPSIDE DOWN WITH HIS NOTS
AND THAT SORT OF BECOMES
CONFUSED FEET CONFUSING WE SAVE
PLAN OUT MY FIRST VISITOR
REACTION IS I'M CONFUSED I'M NOT
SURE.
FEAR UNCERTAINTY DOUBT YOU KNOW
WHAT LET'S JUST WALK AWAY FROM
THIS RIGHT HERE.
BUT IT'S THAT LEADERSHIP THAT
CHARGES FORD.
WHEN THERE'S CONFUSION THAT YOU
[inaudible]
PUT IT.
BUCKLEY WELL MISTER CHAIR FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO WEREN'T HERE
DURING.
OF SENATE BILL.
THREE FIFTY THIS IS NOTHING.
THIS IS NOTHING THE OPPOSITION
IN COMPARISON THE SENATE BILL.
THREE FIFTY YOU WANT TO SEE REAL
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS SPENT.
FEET SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW MUCH WAS
SPENT.
ON THE TOP.
A PLUS PLUS LOBBYIST IN
SACRAMENTO AND ALL THE MAIL
PROGRAM NOW THE TV COMMERCIALS
AND ALL RADIO. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WAS SPENT TO
KILL THE BILL.
THIS OPPOSITION HERE IS NOTHING
COMPARISON AND THE WORD THAT GOD
WANTS TO DO NOTHING THEY'RE
WORTH THE THEY DOING WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
ASSETS.
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY LET'S
MEET THEIR SHAREHOLDERS.
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE AS THE AS
THE BODY TO WE HAVE CONSTANT
CONSTANTLY BAILED OUT ALSO.
TO THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
FOR THEIR OWN INTERNAL MISTAKES
FIFTH WE HAVE BAILED THEM OUT.
TIME AFTER TIME AFTER TIME.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE THE BILL
ABOUT ONCE AGAIN ON A FUTURE
POLICY ISSUES WITH ITS THE
LIABILITY ISSUES WITH THE ISSUES
OF THE FIRE.
THE ISSUE THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION ONCE AGAIN WE GOT
ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE US THAT
THE P. UC'S NOT WANT TO DEAL
WITH THEM THEY PUNTED OVER
[inaudible]
CONVENIENTLY [inaudible]
US.
IT IS LEGISLATIVE BODY.
A POLITICAL BODY WHO HAS TO MAKE
VERY TOUGH DECISIONS OR MAY NOT
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
WE SHALL SEE BUT ALL THESE
EXTERNAL FACTORS ARE NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED.
NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
WE HAVE GROWN WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
I WOULD DISAGREE WITH YOU KNOW
WITH THE GENTLEMAN.
MISTER GALLAGHER WISH SHE WAS
HERE YOU KNOW ONE IMPACT THE
STEP WE HAVE CREATED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY SPACE ALONE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS THE NUMBER.
THAT'S A VERY SERIOUS NUMBER
IT'S NOT A TRUMP UP NUMBER IT'S
NOT CONFLATED [inaudible]
IT'S THERE'S AN ASTERISK THERE
THAT YOU CAN FOOT NOTED
PRECISELY WITH THE METHODOLOGY
TO FIND WHERE EXACTLY FROM
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION WHICH
IS IN ITS NASCENT STAGE.
THE NASCENT STAGE WHICH I'M
GOING TO WATCH WE'RE GONNA WATCH
YOU KNOW --
HE LOOKS LIKE A DOCTOR WITH THE
BOW TIE I KNOW HE'S NOT A DOCTOR
MEAL WITH THE PHD TITLE MISTER
TING.
YOU KNOW A UNLIKE MISSING YOU
KNOW EGGMAN AND MISTER QUIRK
INDELIBLY WHAT THE BOW TIE LOOKS
LIKE ONE BUT WHEN I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING HIM.
ROLE FOR YOU KNOW WHAT
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION AND HIS
GOAL TO GET SO MANY DESERVES OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
ON THE ROADS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
ON THAT ONLY YOU WILL BE THE
LEADER FOR THE STATE'S.
AND BECAUSE THE SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY THAT ALLOWS THAT
SPACE FOR TRANSPORTATION
EDUCATION.
HE STOPS IN THE CHARGING
STATIONS WHICH INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HAVE GONE HEAD IN
FIRST I'LL BE TO COMPETE MARKET
SPACE WITH WHISPER.
THESE ARE THE LEADERSHIP
DECISION THAT WE MAKE IN SPITE
OF ALL THE NOISE SO.
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP --
THAT'D BE STAFF I GOTTA --
A THINK OF STUFF.
TO A THEY HAVE WORKED HARD --
THEY HAVE --
POINTED THINGS THAT WE DID.
AND THAT MADE US THINK TWICE ON
A COUPLE THINGS AND A WITH A MY
STAFF HERE TOO AS WELL YOU KNOW
MY STAFF HAS BEEN FANTASTIC SO
WITH THAT --
MISTER CHAIRS WILL IS MISTER
VICE CHAIRMANAND MEMBERS OF OF
OF OF THIS COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM A BOAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR THERE IS A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY FLOOR ROLL CALL ON THE
MOTION.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
PATTERSON NO [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I GEN [inaudible]
GENDO [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MAYES NO.
MURATSUCHI.
REFUGEE AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING.
TING AYE.
OF THE BILL IS OUT THERE. EIGHT
VOTES IN FAVOR MISTER LEAVE THE
ROLE OF NDA.
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO HAVE THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. TO ADD ON THE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
I CAN THINK CALENDAR
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. [inaudible]
YOU GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MURATSUCHI.
REFUGEE I REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
OKAY WE WILL CALL ON MEMBERS TO
HAVE NOT VOTED ON OUR FIRST ITEM
S. B. WANNA IF [inaudible]
THEY WE HAVE A S. B. I'M SORRY
S. B..
ONE HUNDRED WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDING ON FOR THE
NEXT FIVE MINUTES. FIVE MINUTES
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO S. B.
ONE HUNDRED OR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR
.
WELL IF THE CALL [inaudible]
ON ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
I LIFT THE COLON SP [inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES I
YOU CAN BOTH BE
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
DO YOU THINK [inaudible]
WHAT
[inaudible]
AB
.
RIGHT HERE ON VOTERS WAITED
VOTE.
I THINK.
THAT ALL OF YOUR REPORT COMMENT
WITH REGARD.
TO I WAS HERE.
OKAY SO LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I SANTIAGO.
OKAY THERE FOURTEEN IN FAVOR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THAT IS
[inaudible]
THAT'S OUT.
I WILL LIFT THE CALL ON SB
[inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER NO [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I SO THEIR TWO AN
IN FAVOR.
THAT BILL IS OUT AND WE HAVE.
TAKING CARE OF ALL OF OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THE MEETING
IS ADJOURNED